That's like actually just populism,
but populism for parents when you're not a
I'm having a hard time even taking it remotely seriously. >> I
think that you >> I just pick whatever issue. I decide
how right or wrong something is based on how what percentage
of parents in America would agree with me.
Apparently, my Discord account just got perma suspended.
Oh, okay. That seems insane. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Huh? What?
What? What the What the Wait, what? What are you saying right
now, Adam? >> I can't. I kid. Come on. >> No. Oh,
demps are not as fractured as people think. It's just Dude, you're
the one who argues that they're the individualists. Of course,
the individualists are going to be fractured. Are you stupid?
Perfect. All right. Okay. I Let's move right on to the Adam and
Sitch stuff. Adam and Sitch checked out that Aerodite Desty panel
and I'm going to check it out now. example. >> And for
some reason, now I can't tell you why, but for some reason, they
start like in the middle of this and they don't even do their
intro. I don't know what happened. >> Okay. But they actually,
this is actually how it starts. They don't even do their normal
intro here or something. >> Well, with Asmin Gold, I I
don't think that you I don't think anything that you've said
or done is what pushed him away. I think he's probably afraid
to speak to you because you're much smarter than him and it would
be embarrassing for him. >> Absolutely. Absolutely [__]
true. >> This was
knew that. [__] you for the queen. Okay. and you'd
let him land softly. I bet you if he knew that like if you had
some social capital with him and he knew that you'd let him land
land softly for a few times, I bet you he would more be more
open to talking to you. Particularly, >> you're probably
right. And what you just said is exactly the reason why I will
never talk to these people again is because allowing them to
land softly over and over and over again and only allowing them
to land softly drove me insane and I will never be a part of
that again. Yes, >> I don't know what to tell you. You
you were the one good liberal in their mind view and I know that
you resent >> intro is only supposed to be for the Sunday
stream. Okay, I get it. >> Resent that. I know that you
think that that was bad. >> It's not that I resent it.
It's that when I when you're the one
view you as a liberal. No, it's not a paradigm shift. They go
I like other liberals. >> Yes, they did view you as liberal.
I don't know what the to tell you because I get the feedback
all the time.
You know, they get 100 times more feedback on my own existence
than you get on my existence. Right. You as you said, you're
collecting the wrong data. They absolutely >> they're trying
to hook people in. Okay. They started with a good part of the
the actual stream, the actual debate. They're just trying to
hook people in. >> Do you you as liberal? They just You
Every single person says that you're the good liberal. What the
is that money? You're not liberal. >> When Hold on. When
somebody says somebody says, "Hold on. No, wait. We going to
play this." >> This is amazing, sitch. Why? Why have you
been hiding this from me? >> Cuz you know it's I I wanted
to I wanted to cover things that were important. Okay. I wanted
to talk about >> Obama going to jail. That's not >> I
want to talk about Obama going to >> This is internet cringe.
But everyone said no. They said, "Sitch, you got to deliver to
us Destiny." Uh, doubling down, cringing out, sewing out on the
Wick panel. And I said, "Okay, I will do what the audience asks
of me cuz I'm a good host." >> I like, "Oh man, I had to
show massive restraint not to pause. There's so much cringe in
there to respond to. Holy cow." So Destiny's like, "Yes, I'm
a thousand times smarter than Asmin Gold,
>> right? I am Galaxy Brain compared to Asmin Gold, right?
Isn't >> just going to highlight this message and just
continue. >> Like vastly more popular than Destiny,
>> He's in the millions in the in the millions of subscribers.
Destiny I don't think Destiny has ever broken a million. >> I
think he's No, no, I think he's broke a million or close. >> I
don't think he's got
>> No, not on YouTube. What is he 850? 850 now. Well, I
don't know what he was on Twitch, so he kind of >> I would
say that the idea that your subscriber count is, you know, tied
to your intelligence is just crazy. But >> move from Twitch
over to
YouTube. But let's not dwell on that. There's a this >> There
would be something to be said though that if this is your job
and you know your your job is this and you've been unable to
reach the same heights as Gold, you know, Asmin Gold wasn't really
a political content creator. He's almost all video game content
creators, almost all video game content for quite a while. Then
he got into more social commentary. He didn't even get into like
political commentary until the past year and a half on a consistent
basis. Right. >> Other things here also him talking about
the why no one will talk to Destiny
>> which I think I mean we're pretty much in that camp.
Like why the we want to laugh at Destiny. We don't want to talk
to Destiny. Are you kidding me? Why do we want to Why would we
want to talk to somebody who's completely bad faith whose only
goal is >> Do you check avatars before you highlight them
for safety reasons? No. I just highlighted Scrotum's avatar to
see what it was. Okay. No, I will not check them. No, I will
not.
>> To savage your reputation, right? And act like he's
>> I will I will actually probably screen them at some
point. Like if I don't recognize your name and I want to highlight
your comment, I will probably check it. >> Doing you a
favor for doing it, right? That's fine. You savage your our reputation
on your stream. You don't have to come on our stream to do that,
right? So, >> well, that's where Yeah. And I don't agree
with Naserite on like the cheat she that like what Asthma Gold
or anyone would want is to have Destiny like be soft in them.
It's not a question being soft. It's a question of being feel
conversation with someone. >> Good faith. Yes. >> Right.
or even even a debate with someone where you feel like they're
enga you're engaging with some level of good faith or something
and it's just >> dishonest destiny.
>> Well, I mean it's Destiny is smart but the problem is
that he uses a lot of his intelligence to I feel like >> be
a dishonest piece of [__] >> Dishonest he gets
completely debaterained about the whole thing with this entire
panel. Okay, >> is all about him making the joke about
the kids that die in the flood. >> no way.
Okay, Sitch is Sitch is actually going to set it up. Okay, thank
God. I was >> "Guys, you got to explain what the panel's
about." >> That's what this panel's about. And that entire
situation, okay, is the perfect example of how
>> um actually, you can't uh you can't come up with like
a a moral for why I can't joke about those dead kids. Actually,
you can't do it. There's no moral that says I can't joke about
those dead kids. debate brain rot destiny gets he did a joke
that wasn't funny and also didn't >> hold on can we watch
resi cope on Sunday's stream later also e Sunday I don't even
know what you're talking about soapbox but if you have if there's
some reason it ties into this stream or something I'd be down
to watch it >> really like have a political point to it
or make sense or say anything that was important about anything
and instead of just being like okay like I shouldn't buy that
one right it's just he will forever refuse to ever acknowledge
that he was wrong about it and just double down forever, forever,
forever, forever, forever, forever. >> Oh, I have a theory
why he does this. >> Why that really is? So, I think sometimes
Destiny can get away from from a comment, right, and and get
called on it later and just go, I changed my mind. Okay, but
this is this is unquestionably true. Destiny will say something
stupid and then he will spend like hours and hours and hours
debating why the stupid thing he said is actually correct, right?
like we've watched this and I think that's kind of what makes
him content is he'll he'll say something dumb and then he'll
be like no I'm going to argue this forever. This is now my position.
You know what actually we're going to make an entire thing around
this. Okay. It's very funny >> because everyone who has
done this with him shown uh magnanimity
and and admitted that they were wrong he's used against them
and them over with it. >> That's why that's true. And I
forget who it was. I swear there's somebody that said there was
some person that was one of his friends or something that said
that he just like gets off on the idea of putting himself in
these like um situations that seem intractable and then trying
to claw his way out. >> Oh, really? >> I don't >> I
mean it wasn't one of his friends that said it. He has said it
multiple times that that's like when he feels the most alive
is like when he puts himself in bad situations. That's what he
said after the Mr. Girl thing. That was like him basically off
to the idea that Mr. girl was accusing him of being a serial
abuser. That's like his position >> or maybe some bizarre
thing. But with the
it's the part of this conversation. >> God, very >> I've
never felt more alive than when all these women are accusing
me of being a serial abuser. Just a totally abusive piece of
that like total degenerate.
But guess what, guys? You could check all my messages. My history
is as as clean as it gets, okay? I'm cleaner than anybody else
around. He tweets within like months of him having shared Pixie's
uh recorded with Pixie non-conensually. >> Cool. Because
you know, not so Aerodite is
one of Destiny's business partners. She stay she stuck by him
despite all the stuff that happened. I remember when that all
blew up. People were wondering, you know, she's still going to
do a show with him. And apparently she is. And there's a clip
of her saying on a different stream that I believe owns like
50% of that podcast. So she's getting money for him. in a lot.
>> I love that. By the way, I'm just going to point it
out. They'll they they're not saying it, but the reason they're
aware of this and the reason they start on this time stamp and
the reason they're aware of a cringe Tik Tok content is a certain
clipping channel that they both happen to be fans and fans of
and friends with. Okay. A certain clipping Twitter account. All
right.
I'm just saying that's almost certainly why they know about it,
right?
They're referencing stuff that They're referencing stuff that's
very funny getting put into the ether. >> Lot of this conversation.
It's It's very weird that this is public. A lot of this conversation
feels like not so erodite as a business partner yelling at Destiny
basically saying you're [__] over our business because
you act so unhinged and stupid that you're limiting your audience
and limiting your potential to to grow because big people don't
want to talk to you. Like unfortunately we usually like to laugh
at Erdite. Erdite basically has like a totally correct totally
obviously correct position here, right? Hey, when you joke about
those kids dying, when you make comments about those kids who
are dead, like that is going to make people not want to talk
to you. People will not want to talk to >> Like it totally
comes like that's what this comes off with cuz she's like, "Oh,
a lot of this is why don't you talk to Asthma Gold? Asthma Gold
is the largest streamer. You know, you could definitely like
if Destiny was >> because Aspen Gold is smarter than Destiny.
That's why he's not gonna talk to him. >> He's a [__]
idiot. >> If if this was Destiny from Kyle Renhouse time
period and he was like less, you know, unhinged.
Of course, he he'd have openings. Yeah, he talked to Jordan Peterson.
He talked to Ben Shapiro. >> He could definitely be on
Asmold stream and he could definitely, you know, gain a larger
following because a lot of >> Yeah. Yeah, I would never
say that Destiny's like not Destiny's like dumber than Asmin
Gold. I don't really have any investment there, right? I do think
Asminold's smarter than you might think given the stupid he says,
right? I think he is smarter than you might think, but uh I think
Asminold is smart enough to know that he is nothing to be gained
by talking to Destiny. It could only hurt him, so he'll never
do it. people that watch Asthma Gold who are not just totally
in in the Trump camp would probably also watch Destiny and but
that's all going out the window because he just can't help himself.
>> Interesting. He sees that marshmallow and he's like
I got to eat that
>> Yes. Yes. It is a complete lack. Okay, you guys don't
like Adam. I get it. I know Adam. So, listen, by the way, Adam
and Sitch together make great content, right? They are great
content creators when combined. Sitch. Uh, I don't know. I can't
say because I like Sitch's independent commentary, but like Sitch
gets a lot out of Adam throwing things out from his perspective
and Sitch is able to say, "Okay, this is how I like it. This
is this is like I like this comment, but I disagree here." Right?
Sitch is willing to give his opinion and Adam sort of like keeps
the conversation flowing in a direction like they work they work
off of each other very well. Also, what Adam just said there
is entirely correct. the marshmallow thing. This is a reference
to a self-control, an impulse control experiment that basically
predicts success in adult life, right? Destiny does not have
impulse control. He does not have any self-control. And that's
what gets him into trouble all of the time is he does not have
that impulse control. He can't not eat the marshmallow.
Right. >> Okay. So, let's go through this. Obviously, we're
not going to watch the whole thing today. It's 3 hours and 38
minutes. But >> who's this who's I don't remember this
girl's name, but she was on our stream and she was super cool.
So, >> what is it? Tally. >> Tally. That's right.
>> Uh yeah, shout out to Tally because uh Tally got a lot
of great comments in our when she was on our stream. So, she
seemed to be a crowd favorite. So, she's welcome back on the
show anytime. >> Yes. And I like the things that she was
saying most. >> She was good faith >> panel, too.
She Oh, our favorite Connor. Can Connor come back on the stream?
>> you're the one. What are you What are you asking me?
Con I'm >> didn't Wait, didn't Adam I think Adam like basically
said he would never have Connor on again, didn't he? Wasn't that
after one of their previous conversations? He basically said
Connor was such bad faith that he didn't want him around anymore.
What was that over? I think that might have been over PV funding.
I can't remember for sure. I remember Adam like blew him up though
if I'm pretty sure. I gotta I gotta figure that out and see where
their last conversation was because I remember Adam being super
heated about it. >> I've never banned Connor from the stream.
I never
>> Every time I try every every time I try to bury the
hatchet with Connor, though,
>> It doesn't seem like Connor wants to bury the hatchet.
>> Seems like Connor is still >> Well, he says things
that he says a lot of things in this conversation that you're
probably going to agree with. >> Okay, good. Maybe since
maybe getting fired from progressive victory. >> I'm not
sure if that's what it was, Sherry. Not sure. >> Attack
hypocrisy to like a whole crowd of millions of people. like that
is a conversation starter as much as you might not like it. >> So,
so Stephen, that that's an important question. Did uh did you
think that you were going to become a is this a an avantguard
marketing strategy? Did you think you were going to get a invite
from Pierce Morgan? You're like, I'm going to tweet out about
dead kids a and this is 100% going to result in people inviting
me onto their shows. >> Holy, I said that exact thing on
stream. >> Yes, we you're going to get an answer to your
question or well, some you're going to get you're going to hear
an answer. Wait, but that is that is 100% correct, right? That
is one of the goals is he gets to be the he gets to be the uh
crackhead Barney of the Piers panel in that case, right? He gets
to say totally things. He he is Piers Morgan's lolcow, right?
He is a lull for Piers Morgan and some other big content creators.
>> Well, that's crazy. Conor's asking this. Look, obviously
Connor believes that's the case, too. Otherwise, why would he
be asking this question?
Well, the the guy who I've never heard of him before, I think
his name is Soy Pill. Not a big fan of him in this conversation.
Uh he was positing that everyone should shut up about Destiny
said he jokes because it actually helps him because that's what
got him on Pierce Morgan. >> Right. Okay. >> Which
is the theory that you laid out was Destiny's intention from
the >> Yeah. But I don't I don't know if it helps him.
Right.
>> I mean, Piers Morgan is going to invite you on because
you're cringe.
Right. Ben Shapiro doesn't want to talk to you
cringe lords, right? Uh
Asmin Gold doesn't want to deal with a bunch of edgy cringe lords,
right? >> Asmin Gold just doesn't talk to people, honestly.
Asmin Gold just doesn't really collab unless it's something directly
related to his interests. I don't think Asmin Gold wants to take
like I don't know if Asmin Gold would collab with a lot of political
content creators online that aren't mainstream ones. >> Well,
just not his model. Asmin Gold makes a of money watching videos
and giving his reaction, his take. Mhm. >> Why? He's not
in the debate bro sphere. Why would he even want to enter the
debate bro sphere? What's the incentive for him to do that? >> There's
no incentive. >> I mean, we're we're kind of in the react.
I mean, obviously, we do some overlap with the debate, but neither
one of us have really
I mean, I did a bunch of debates, but I didn't do it. Um, >> we
never fully jumped into like we're doing full-time debate.
>> Yes. I tried to do a debate a week on my think club
channel just to for fun just to try and talk about different
things that I was interested in. Unfortunately, a lot of the
stuff that I'm interested in is like repellent for audiences.
They are not interested in economics or anything like that. So,
>> and it well it's difficult because like if you look
at it from Asma Gold's perspective or any other streamer who
doesn't do debate content regularly perspective,
they
you know >> Lo seems inaccurate. A lot of comments on the
Piers video were on his side. DG AstroTurf as possible. I guess
I would just Yeah, go look at those who's making those comments.
Like the DG people are the most like once you build that following,
it's very um like DGG is becoming very very close to what the
Gropers are, right? Where it's like yeah, the audience isn't
as big as it used to be, right? The audience is sort of diminishing,
but the people remaining are like the most devout followers of
the cult, right? Hold on. I'm uh I'm looking at this. Like they
will engage everywhere. They will engage absolutely everywhere.
They will engage hard. They will go and comment on everything.
They will like everything. Distillation is a good word to use
for this anal. Yes. Right. Like these are the lowest IQ.
Lowest IQ. Least least like uh Oh, these people none of these
people have internal monologues. They are just bots to be directed,
right? That's those are the only people remaining there. That's
it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like I don't think it's it's not quite
the same thing. And obviously I know I posted this. Obviously
I'm not comparing the the beliefs, right? I'm never I'm never
going to say DGG's beliefs are relatively equivalent to what
the Griopers beliefs are. They're not. I don't I don't care to
make that claim. I don't think it's even close, right? Obviously
the the core beliefs of the Gropers would be far worse. But I'm
saying the behaviors some of the behaviors and like the cult-like
dynamics, the the overinvestment in the internet, I think that's
very similar. I think those dynamics transfer over and are they
map on quite well. There's no reason to engage or interact with
Destiny or someone else who's a big debate bro type because
if they disagree with them because all that person is going to
try to do is weaken and destroy their credibility in front of
their own >> It's like why would you ever invite well like
what is the point of even doing >> Yes. Now, I think what
Naserite is trying to convey to Destiny here is that you could
theoretically go onto those streams and not be a debate bro and
just have a conversation and you can disagree with things and
point things out and, you know, you could maybe they would have
you on. You could have an interesting conversation and that that
could all play out that way. I think the problem is that I I
think it's too late for Destiny. He's his >> Yeah, this
comment is essentially Yeah, exactly. the point it makes >> the
brand has already been set. The idea of who he is has already
been set. I don't think he can change it at this
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It is interesting cuz I don't I just I don't think Destiny
has a broad base a broad enough base of knowledge to actually
have interesting conversations like you and I constantly reading
constantly look. >> Yeah, I got this cuz I stream tourniquet.
I didn't get this cuz I was like going around and commenting
on every YouTube video. That's the difference, right? Like I'm
saying the the the worker ants, the the worker ants, you know,
the drones, those are the people that like make that community
kind of groper like, right? It's the people who will just take
direction and do exactly what's said. Um, and you know, I don't
I don't not exactly clean hands here. I farm those people a lot.
I made a lot of money, a lot of a lot of Twitter follows, a lot
of, you know, social media engagement from exactly those drones.
I know who they all are, right? They used to comment on my posts
and agree with me. They're just they're just drones though. They'll
just go whichever way Destiny signals. >> Looking into
new things, constantly absorbing new topics.
Destiny doesn't do any of that. >> I don't know if I agree
with that. I >> Okay. What is What is Destiny absorbing
that we're not >> I don't Well, actually, you're right.
I don't know. Like I don't I don't watch Destiny content in a
long time, so I don't know what content he uh reads besides like
whatever the topic of the day is. I would assume he's fairly
knowledgeable about a lot of topics and has an opinion on a lot
of topics. I think the issue is not I think the issue is not
that he's not has a broad knowledge base. I think the issue is
a is a combination of of his
and his and his ego to just not like have that conversation with
someone about some topic like that. I mean he actually that's
not true because he used to back in the day he used to have more
topics broadly about philosoph like philosophical concepts and
other things you know which is I don't know he just seems to
be spiraling out now >> he focuses
monoomaniacally
on a topic and learns every
detail of it right he knows every single detail of January 6
>> he doesn't know the broad he's not reading books about
the law the constit institution right economics >> books
I don't think he reads >> so this is what I mean by he
doesn't have a broad base of knowledge like he has a super detailed
level of knowledge about certain things
but
>> learning about how everything comes together like he
doesn't know selectorate theory he doesn't know moral found uh
moral found moral psychology he doesn't know moral foundation
theory he doesn't know any of these broad topics
>> at the I Desie probably doesn't know some of the broader
topics and he's like not as uh narratively driven as a lot of
other people are. He's more mostly looking for like what facts
can I use to win an argument. It's like a different way of engaging.
I don't really care to say like one way of engaging is better
or worse than the other. I do think Destiny's way of engaging
essentially works to frustrate people who do the narrative thing.
And so people anybody who operates in narratives really hates
that way of way of talking. Right. Sometimes though, like sometimes
the narratives are like correct or you want to push in that direction
and you have somebody like let's say I think Israel Palestine
might be the best version of this where like yes from the facts
you can prove it sure looks like you know it's hard to blame
Israel for very much but realistically if you were operating
from Destiny's worldview then you would basically be thinking
that you know Gaza is not totally on October 12th 2023 right
if you're operating in that worldview you'd look at the facts
you'd basically be able to dismiss all of the criticisms of Israel
and say, "Okay, like Israel is not really that bad." And then
you but the narrative worldview obviously sees like some of what
Israel is doing. It's just very difficult to to pin down and
prove how they're bad, right? With a lot of like facts or a lot
of statements, a lot of uh you know, laws they have or any anything
they've done specifically in terms of international diplomacy,
it's very difficult to prove down how they're bad or sorry to
pin down how they're bad. But I I think a lot of like the narrative
people kind of had it and you can miss the forest for the trees
sometimes when all you focus on is like exactly what is harshly
proven or or strongly proven out and you only operate from those
facts. >> The end of this uh dev,
you know, talks about a height and Destiny just doesn't agree
with it. He just dismisses the whole thing. So >> because
see, and this is this is why Destiny is useless because now that
he's disagreed with Hold on. I want to highlight this be very
vivic comment. So, I'm not saying that that's wrong. Be very
vivic. What I'm saying is I think the predictive power of that
way of thinking can be pretty bad sometimes and those people
tend to be far more reassured in in like what they've proven
out and it will be difficult for them to change their minds.
I don't think the way of thinking is like all bad. I think probably
Destiny's strictly political commentary I don't necessarily like
disagree with or hate in a lot of cases. Obviously, who he is
as a person, he's like a terrible person, right? Um, but I I
don't necessarily think it's bad. I'm just saying that there
are some things that it can miss. There are some ways that that
way of thinking is less good for maybe. I don't know how I'm
I'm trying to describe it, but >> that on a stream >> in
front of everybody. >> Even if he read the book and thought
there's some merit here. He couldn't say that or do or or
express that, right? >> He he spoiled >> I'm not
talking about him post hawk rationalizing. Be very vivic because
you're saying point out examples. I gave you the example of Israel
Palestine, right? Where he was very defensive of Israel and obviously
Israel's like committed massive excesses now and he still at
times feels like he has to commit back to defending Israel again,
right? And I'm I'm saying that like I think that there are a
lot of people if you were narratively driven, you could predict
that quite a bit better. And I think that it was based on some
facts, but you
uh I have to I'd have to write down some thoughts on this to
describe it correctly. But yeah, I just don't think that that
way of thinking is necessarily good all the time in terms of
its predictive power. Now, I think the response from anybody
who uses that sort of way of thinking would be, "Yeah, but the
predictive power is less wrong than most other things most of
the time." You expound on narratively driven. No, I can't right
now. I literally have to write stuff down because I'm just going
off of intuition and it's uh I'm going to say something that
I like haven't thought about and then I'll look. So, I'm just
going to chill and watch this good old watch watch the content
we're watching for a little bit. Okay. We I It's funny because
we had this conversation on stream maybe two years ago, maybe
three years ago.
Look, and I now I don't remember if we had it on stream or or
didn't have it on stream, but we talked about how
if you broadly dismiss something out of hand that I'm bringing
new because it's something that I I've I've read about, then
that taints the audience in one direction or another, and we
shouldn't do that because maybe there's relevance to it and maybe
there's not, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. No, that's a good point.
>> Destiny does that
>> on everything always,
>> Which it's terrible, right?
>> You You're souring your audience to something that could
be true or useful just to make internet dunk points. I don't
think Asmin Gold would ever do that to be honest with you. >> Do
what? Dismiss something out of hand? >> I I mean I'm not
sure. >> I haven't watched enough content. I wouldn't be
surprised. He's very opinionated. So, >> I've never seen
him do that. It's every time Asmin look, I haven't seen a lot
of Asmin Gold content. So, maybe I should just listen to a whole
stream and see how many
>> he says that I disagree with.
>> You've got a lot more disagreement with Asmin Gold and
I've just got haven't really watched much of his content. So,
>> you see like because a lot of his content that gets
a lot of views has like a one minute two minute clip. So obviously,
you know, you can't get a lot of like information from >> uh
Ace is already Look, Ace, we were talking about inviting you
on during super chats, so you might want to like mellow out a
little already. His first super chat is Adam, you're allowing
your hate, you're allowing your >> Oh, sure. Be very vivic.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Is clouding >> here. I think um >> judgments
maybe super chats, too, while you're at it. >> We're going
to let this run for about uh another minute and then I think
I have some time stamps for later on. Okay, give me two seconds.
I'll be right back.
Well, let me just read it to you because you as for $10. Thank
you. Says that and says whenever someone upsets you, paint them
in the worst light possible. Hush and tiny are the best example
of the I mean I don't think you need to paint Destiny in the
worst light. I think >> Yeah. paints himself. >> What
do you What do you contest? Look, Destiny I don't I don't think
Destiny is acting in good faith. I don't think Destiny gives
people the benefit of the doubt. I think Destiny Look, I I think
Sitch and I are both uh good people. Obviously, we don't like
Destiny, but I think I don't like Destiny because his moral character
is trash.
>> And uh he probably doesn't like us because we have principles
and we're going to say that his moral character is trash instead
of just like doing what not so Ariodite is doing and trying to
uh transform him because we have some sort of vested interest
in him. We don't have a vested interest in him. He can go his
way and we can go our way. I could I could tell you Destiny's
response to that because it's his response to every part of this
conversation in this three and a half hour panel.
>> What about Donald Trump? >> No way. You're kidding
me. >> I'm not. >> You're kidding me. >> The
whole conversation is what about Donald Trump? >> He's
so desperate. Oh, he's just become a lull cow. He's totally become
a lull >> But here, let's Okay, so here's answer about
did he say the joke just to get on Pierce Morgan? >> Look,
we got to cover more. Look, the >> Why are people shocked
that that's the uh Why are people shocked that that's the line?
That's literally the line he used to get out of his uh his what
do we call it? Crimes and indiscretions, right? It's it's the
same line he used to get out of that. Guys, or at least that
his fans use, right, guys? Are you are you sure that we really
want to pay attention to Destiny? You know, non-consentually
spreading of people. Are you sure you want to pay attention to
him non-conensually recording situations? Are you sure we want
to pay attention to that, guys? When Donald Trump is in office,
when fascism is on the rise? Can we really afford to pay attention
to any of this?
>> I I hate the the meme that either of us have TDS because
every anytime we criticize Trump, sometimes people accuse us
of having TDS, but we got to cover more Destiny stuff because
he just makes us look so much. He just screams TDS. So, I'll
leave you guys with that >> possibly. I would just like
to clarify one part of the joke, though. You said that it was
gross that they were underage and it was a joke. Well, that was
why God was punishing them. If they were adults that were using
NordVPN to watch, then God wouldn't punish them. So, it wouldn't
make any sense, would >> God was punish
Oh my god, the the joke is logical, Connor. Don't you get it?
Of course, I made a logical joke.
>> Did he actually use that excuse? Well, his fans do.
Uh, I think it's like his fans and not so I did quite >> the
whole thing too like it wasn't he's never like explained at least
in these films I've watched like what is the there's not like
a political point to the like he keeps acting like there's some
like grander political thought to the joke or that it means something
deeper and it doesn't. >> No, no, no. I I don't even think
that's what he argues. We'll see what where Sitch goes with this.
He's basically arguing that like there's no moral. Like unless
you want to take a position that offensive jokes are wrong. You
can't give him like a moral aught for why he shouldn't make that
joke. Right? There is no moral ought. So then from there it's
like just his decision. There's no moral claim there. So it's
just his decision on whatever he wants to do and he wants to
make the the weird joke. Right now, Erdite sits here and she's
like, "Well, I, you know, am your business partner and I feel
really weird when you make these jokes and I feel really weird
when we have, you know, joint business ties and you're up my
my uh what do you call it? My collabs and right, that me off,
but there is no moral claim unless you want to unless that's
why they keep bringing it up toite like do you want to say bad
joke like uh dark jokes are like morally wrong or hey, there
are some jokes you shouldn't make."
That's that's what he's pushing. But that leaves like a whole
bunch of you you basically ignore everybody in the middle who
it doesn't engage with like moral philosophy who's just like,
"Yeah, you're weird. Yeah, you're weird, bro." That's like 95%
of people are just like, "Yeah, you're you're weirdo. You're
weirdo. Why you being so weird?" It's just like a weird
I mean I guess is it supposed to be about how like there's some
crazy right-wing people who whenever a natural disaster happens
they'll say like oh well God did this to smite the gays. Like
that's what I feel like he's saying with the joke which is like
okay 2005 is calling right like I feel like we're >> not
typically a liberal joke but what whatever. No, but I mean even
like conservatives today,
like there were some conservatives on X that I saw when the LA
fires were happening that were like making the weird, you know,
God is punishing LA thing, but they it definitely wasn't like
even the it wasn't any of the big right-wing commentators I saw
that would even dip into any of that stuff. It weird like the
weirdo Christian nationalist people would say like that. >> Yeah.
Ben Shapiro is not coming out and saying, "Well, look, the hurricane
took out the gays." >> Right. Right. Right. Right. >> It's
so weird question cuz not it's not only are you say not only
are the dead kids dead, but you're saying they're also hypocrites,
right? Because they're they're not really religious, they're
watching in their free time and getting around it. Getting around
their religious conviction. It's just it's so nasty. Uh >> yeah,
it's a it's a very nasty joke. >> Um did I know I invite
I don't know. Maybe maybe not. Um I generally at this point when
it comes to educating conservatives I don't >> all the
big Yeah, be very vivic. You're like totally following down the
wrong path on this. I understand that like um you might do this
with Sitch and Adam. That's fine. I'm not I honestly was listening
to Sitch just a little bit there. Mostly looking at the chat,
but like it's not that that that can't be you can't use this
joke and then say I want to draw attention to the the weirdo
comments from the LA fires cuz it's not equivalent, right? those
people weren't using like dead kids to try to make those points.
They just weren't right. It's like not equivalent at all. You
can you can try to say that, but it's just like a M Bailey necessarily
make these jokes with like this some huge grand master plan in
mind. Um, I just think liberals need to be way less soy about
making fun of uh conservatives for they've like moved the window
of acceptable behavior so unbelievably far in one direction that
at this point I refuse to be policed by actual subhuman degenerate
filth about what we can or can't joke about when they make the
most I mean the it's not he's not just offending subhuman degenerate
filth. He could easily offend only subhuman degenerate filth,
right?
But he's not he's not even remotely those aren't even the primary
target. All you'd have to do is make fun of Greg Abbott getting
kids, right? That's all you would say. Those kids die because
Greg Abbott's a piece of [__] That's like all you
have to say. And every Republican will get and then you don't
have anybody else there. Most unhinged degenerate jokes ever.
And I have seen absolutely >> Okay. I just Oh god. [__]
I hate this guy. I hate this guy. >> What about the whole
thing is what about >> uh am I missing? Are you talking
to me, Alpha Kilo? No, it's a direct attack. It's at that town.
You can't possibly be talking to me, right? You're you're you
got to be you got to be saying something else here, right? You're
not saying that joking about NordVPN and those kids off is like
a direct attack on that town, right? We're not saying that. I
just need to make sure we're not saying that.
>> Well, and it's just he's he's saying all conservatives
are are degenerate filth, right? Imagine
saying imagine categorizing all black people as
>> How How does he do this? How the does he do this? It's
just Oh my god. It's so bad. It's so bad. So bigoted. Zero evidence
whatsoever that this go low, go high, whatever has ever worked
ever for liberals. It seems like all of the most popular moments
have usually been when they're kind of roasting the other side
a little bit. So yeah, I don't know. And I feel like liberals
are the ones that have the most negative reaction. >> One
is that >> I mean I do unfortunately I I do agree. It seems
like right now the mood is
>> is that not what he argues? Yeah, but that it it doesn't
matter. How is saying those kids died because they they were
off to without NordVPN or they were using a VPN to get How does
that criticize the town?
If you want to explain to me, if you want to give me an argument
on how that criticizes the town, you go ahead. I would love to
hear it. I would actually love to hear that >> whoever
is just like the best at
uh stuff to dunk on their side is gaining the biggest traction
in the political space
on both the left and the right. I see on the on the right it's
all, you know, oh my god, you know, Obama's going to jail. The
Democrats, all the Democrats, all the libtars, they're all like
insane. And I go on the right and it's like Donald Trump is spiraling
out of control. Here's the next. Look at this crazy thing that
he said. Oh my god. Has he had like a mental brain fart when
he said this in the press today, you know? This just all that's
all that's going on right now. >> Yeah. Because there's
no >> Dingling is a fundamental misunderstanding of the
critical theory thing. Okay. That's that is that is what explains
all Republican action. Okay. That's what explains all of it.
They're on the side of kids. They're on the side of like this
innocent thing and they make it so that you can't actually you
can't really attack them, right? like they're they're going to
say it's all about protecting kids. >> There's no election.
It's just 30% of the population is partisan one way or the other.
And the other the 40% are independents are not really paying
attention to politics to the point, you know, they're not really
getable. They're doing other things,
>> So, I get >> I think it slows down here for a
little bit. I was going to skip forward just a little bit. I
think I have some time stamps coming up here. We'll we'll get
we'll get moving forward. And the remaining 5% watch the Sitch
and Adam
>> you saved it right there at the end. I was like, "Holy,
talk about punching down, Sitch. You just made fun of 95% of
>> the world." >> Yes. Everyone that doesn't watch
us. Hold on. >> Free will. >> I miss time stamps.
>> If somebody can sit in an area,
>> they're not worth appealing to. You're better off energizing
your own side. If somebody can sit in an area >> Oh, that's
telling.
He's better off energizing your own side. But they look at one
guy and they see him 100 people and then they look over there
like well that guy like uh you know he made some rude comments
about you know some woman's bra or whatever. I so I think these
two things like I'm really undecided you you never even waste
time with that person. You just try to appeal to you energize
your own side or maybe you find people who are genuinely legitimately
in the middle but if there are people like I said I haven't seen
the tally stuff but if this is somebody who's legitimately like
undecided about both sides this person's you don't waste your
time with that person. Why would you tell you're trying to protect
the average moderate is I'm telling you that the average moderate
is
clip clip it and just and the Democrats will never win cuz you
just said that we're we're done. Why' you say it? >> Actually,
I disagree. I believe that democracy works with I actually think
that it does. I think it's baked into the system to assume that
people are stupid. Okay, >> I also agree. But but you're
talking you're saying on one side, Stephen, I love that you can
go out and be this person who reaches out to people. However,
because you made this edgy joke or because you cross a line sometimes
that's like poison to the thing and it's like wait hold on you're
quoting >> that's not the criticism >> people that
again be very said it earlier it's just like who did this energize
on his side right you keep saying you want to energize your side
who the did this energize you got a whole bunch of people on
your side saying hey this is really weird I don't want to be
associated with this who are you energizing you're energizing
the people who don't care about you kids that's who You've energized.
>> At events that say they like him, they're Republican.
They're conservatives and they still show up despite not liking
the thing that he said. Clearly
entertainment because they would ever side with him in any political
agreement
>> If you guys agree with me, then why? Well, he's walking
away now. Why is Steven right now saying don't reach the abandon?
It sounds like you guys disagree with each other as well. I mean,
I don't think you should call it racist, even though I do think,
as I said, 95% of the world is you should look at the perspective
of
I do think there's a lot of people, especially younger people,
excuse me, a lot of younger people who
support Trump
and are part of the Trump movement that are not conservative
in terms of their, you know, how they view the world, in terms
of their, if they took a height, you know, moral foundation test,
I don't think they'd necessarily some sort of like far-right
conservative or anything like that. It's just because, >> you
know, they grew up in a time period where the left seemed unhinged.
The vibe of the left was very beta soy,
was very racist against white people, against men, and was just
generally had a vibe of of being whiny and uncool. And the right
definitely seemed more fun and cool and edgy. You know, there
was a comparison that you would I would see this all during the
election. I'm sure you guys saw saw it too. All during the election,
there'd be the compilations of people at Trump rallies and you
see everyone's having fun, everyone's happy, you know, Trump
rallies were like fun, joyous events and then you I kind of So,
we'll see where we jump around in this. I do I I like Sich's
analysis most of the time. I just want to see where when once
Connor like hammers down to it, like basically Connor at some
point halfway through this debate just starts going my only criticism
is like maybe don't children below 15. Maybe don't make comments
about children below 15. You you shouldn't do that, right? The
real the real thing here is just you are not socially equipped
to understand how this affects most people. So you have this
big platform and you're represent you're a representative of
like liberals, right? and you are openly out here like kids and
you don't know how to make those jokes funny for more people.
You don't know when to make those jokes. You're not socially
equipped to make those jokes. So, you should just refrain because
you are driving people away. You're making people like not want
to be near you. You would see a Democrat rally whether for Biden
for for Harris and it would be like everyone was angry and miserable
and then they would also show like oh someone with a Trump hat
goes into the Democrat rally and they get hit with all this hate
and someone with a Harris hat goes into the the Trump rally.
This was actually what I said while we were reacting to the initial
stream. Zanakali was like, remember Destiny, when you tell like
people that they can't neg women because they're not they're
not a gigachad like you, right? They're not a gigachad like you.
You you tell them that
this is this is the same the same rule applied to you in this
situation. You don't have enough experience with like being a
human being and understanding people and like uh generally showing
empathy. You you're not equipped. So you actually should refrain
from commenting here ever. You're actually just causing more
harm to everyone by commenting >> or someone with Trump
would go into the butt the hair. >> If a tragedy happens,
you should stay away. You are not equipped with like uh normal
tools of human empathy and understanding. You don't have that
off for a little bit. Okay. Off for a little bit, dude. He would
grow his platform so much faster. >> Yeah. And someone
with a Trump hat would go someone with a Harris hat would go
in the Trump rally and people would just kind of laugh it off
and not be super offended by it. And so that was generally I
think the vibe that attracts people to that attracts a lot of
people to these movements. >> Yeah, it is interesting because
so much of it is vibes. There's there's two unique strategies
here that I think are at odds with one another, which is kind
of interesting because you you do have base elections, right,
where you're just going to cater to the base. And in that case,
you're going to try a strategy of red meat for the base, right?
We're going to try to energize our people to show up. and and
the more they hate the other side, the more likely they are to
show up, right? But then there are the >> Okay, so one
one strategy, two strategies at odds. He's saying Dusty's trying
to do both. So energize the base >> coalition elections,
which you're really trying to sway the moderates, right? >> Oh,
he's talking about in general, this is like a dynamic politics.
Okay. >> Because the the moderates are probably going to
be turned off by the red meat stuff or the base, right? >> So
you definitely have to dial that stuff back. You're going to
lose some energy from your base. >> Yeah. And I mean that
strategy kind of plays into the social media sphere, the audience
building sphere, right? The the I'm the streamer sphere, right?
Entertaining people who are interested in politics. >> Yeah.
Yeah. And there's it's interesting because like if you look at
the kind of going back to the other thing, if you look at the
comedian podcast circuit, you have your Andrew Schultz, Joe Rogan,
and people like that. Lots of people who supported Trump or seem
to be pushed in a more rightward direction. Those are all people
that like 100 >> This panel took place a while back. Steven
Jian, this is um this is Adam and Sitch reviewing the battle.
We reviewed this entire battle >> really because of like
policy was the driving factor. It was just the vibe. It was just
because the left was like super mean to them. >> Have we
gotten to the part where Wick insults Queen and Sitchin Adams
chat? >> Personally, was attacking them trying to cancel
them, get them in trouble, and the right was just nice to them.
And what do you know when one side's very mean to you, the other
side's very nice to you? Oh, all those people go to the other
side. >> They go, "Oh, this these people are nice to me.
Obviously, I'm going to go to this side." You have the people
like Destiny and other people who are more like following specific
uh like the politics of the situation and specific um policies
that these are saying they start foaming at the mouth and raging
like how the is Joe Rogan people supporting Trump you know if
they don't support all these policies are so stupid and it's
like okay they're based on like one side was like horribly mean
to them and the other side was woken them with open arms obviously
you know where do you think they're going to >> yeah it's
not policy based at all >> yeah I don't obviously that
kind of backfire said he maybe not was going to support Trump
and then his new base tried to cancel him but that's right he
got shamed into doing it >> he did get shamed into doing
it >> he was going to vote for Kennedy Yep. >> The
more things change, the more they stay the same. >> Yeah.
I don't I remember in when George W. Bush ran, Carl Rove was
his his chief campaign strategist, and he came right out and
said, "This is going to be a base election. We have enough conservatives
in the right areas that we just have to get the base out." >> So,
obviously, if if you're going if you're employing that strategy,
you can do the red meat strategy. I don't know that anyone on
the left >> has ever really had a strategy, right? >> Well,
the the thing here is the red meat strategy doesn't work as well
for Democrats because their base is fractured, right? They have
a much larger base, but you can't really do the red meat for
the base thing in the same way because the base is different.
They don't have like a base for Trump. The populist base is like
probably 30% to 40% of his coalition is like the populist base
that he can run the same narrative with. I would argue that Democrats
do not have a coalition that big that they can just throw red
meat for the base. Uh in the same way, unless you want to say
it's the Trump thing, but then I that's like just partisan politics.
It's not really the same, right? But in terms of the issues,
they don't have a base that they can communicate to in the same
way that Republicans can where they can all align with Trump
and they will have that big chunk that will always turn out.
It's not the same thing. >> Like what is their strategy?
Turn
>> they didn't really have a clear uh message or >> only
mute this flies in the face of your entire entiretick. You're
saying, "Oh, hold on. Let me pull this up on stream." Nah. Oh,
Dems are not as fractured as people think. It's just dude, you're
the one who argues that they are the individualists. Of course,
the individualists are going to be fractured. Are you stupid?
The conservatives are the collectivists. They are the ones who
can get who are together. They will follow the same narrative.
That's your thing. How are you arguing against your own point
right >> Anyway, I'll continue. >> Well, I don't
even even Obama, I don't think I don't remember having a strategy
or I just I've never heard it from anyone other than Carl Rove.
I believe I mean I mean I think I'm trying to remember Carl Ro
as the money ball of politics when he was when >> I'm sure
there's some clip of David Axelrod talking about whether they
thought it was a base election or moderate I I would imagine
with Obama they thought they were going to do a broad coalition
>> Obama is a an example of somebody who could who did
who was able to throw red meat to the base but he didn't even
have to. Obama had a coalition of like black voters and and um
like middle- class white voters that just like he had a base
where he could say the same points and people would listen. It
was like different. Obama like created his own base that he could
do this with. >> They created some new coalition of of
>> Well, and they mastered social media. They figured out
that if they could have
>> their operatives contact people on social media and
make a commitment to vote that they would show up and vote, >> right?
And to to be fair to the situation regarding Carl Rove, good
old Turb Blossom,
>> um he was wrong technically with the first election
because George Bush probably lost. >> He barely
squeaked by. Yeah, >> he barely squeaked by because a bunch
of uh leftwing
in West Palm Beach, Florida couldn't read the ballot properly.
>> Well, you don't you don't have to be right or wrong
to to employ the strategy to say, "Look, this is what we're going
to do." >> And I just I >> Okay, I feel like I've
talked about this as much as I want to. So fundamentally at odds
with one another, right? >> I mean it's kind of destiny's
dilemma too cuz he did for he did try to sway the moderate >> strategy
for a bit obviously when he's like reaching out to Nicolentes
and completely his reputation. >> His so he's trying to
>> I don't like I don't think you can can you accuse Destiny
of being like the worst partisan and of also laundering Fuentes?
I feel like you have to pick >> Well, it depends because
also there's like the strategy for becoming bigger on YouTube
or on the internet would probably be very different than the
strategy of winning an election >> in terms of who you
appeal to. Well, I mean even that, >> dude, the corruption,
be very vivic, is insane. Yes, >> the corruption is nuts
right now. >> There are celebrities and entertainers that
have giant audiences that are they try to be more familyfriendly
and stuff like that because they don't want to they don't want
to alienate any any potential audience, right? So, they're not
really employing a red meat strategy or an edgy strategy. I I
guess what would you really call that in the entertainment sphere?
I guess you have to look specifically at politics. >> Yeah,
that's I mean, I would say and I think this is where people miss
the analysis on Destiny. Destiny is not really trying to do he
could say he's trying to energize base. Destiny is not doing
that, right? Destiny is filtering for the people who love watching
him have no impulse control. He's filtering for people who love
a local, right? A local who can seem intelligent, right? Basically,
there's a whole bunch of people. It's this exact level of like
Reddit intellect where they're like, I hate reality TV, but they
love reality TV, right? They love it. And so they they go to
Destiny, they listen to he can make good arguments and debates
and be reality TV at the same time. That's who he's that's who
he's going for, right? And he's going to filter down to those
people who want the very offensive, very low impulse control.
I'm just going to spur about whatever the [__] is
upsetting me at this at any given moment in time, right? That's
who he's filtering down to. And that's what he's trying to do.
There is no real consideration of a political movement. In fact,
in this very debate, not will ask, "Hey, if you have to choose
between growing your your audience and your political movement,
which do you choose?" And he goes, "Well, I can't choose." Right?
He refuses to answer that question. Totally refuses to answer
that question. And it's obvious why, right? He knows that he's
not making politically like expedient or politically effective
choices. He knows that. He's just trying to build up his audience
and the people who will let him do whatever the he wants to do.
The people who will never hold him accountable for anything he
says. He just filters those people out over time. >> I'm
looking at this and I keep thinking Destiny's after that David
Pacman money. He sees all those videos about how Trump is deranged
and cognitively, >> oh no, I hate this. No, >> he's
like, I want that. >> He could do that, but >> David
Pacman is not going to be making jokes about that. >> David
Pacman isn't David Pacman is smart. Yeah, >> he's not if
he wants to go >> Wick TV. Yes, there is an Oh, hold on.
Can you guys even see this? I'll try to pull it up. Oh, okay.
Here we go. Uh, yes, there is an issue where we have uh we have
where the incentives to succeed as a streamer/political influencer
is at even is often at odds with how to succeed in a general
election. Oh, actually Wick's saying good things. >> He
agreed in terms of growing even larger and larger. There's all
sorts of these leftwing commentators who make these videos every
day. It's just Donald Trump has seizure. Donald Trump's brain
and they all get, you know, hundreds of thousands, not millions
of views. Hype. How does this theory mesh with multi-our multi-day
Wikipedia reading? Um, it doesn't really.
It doesn't. I do think there was a time where Destiny decided,
oh, I'm going to try to be like a more serious political commentator.
I'm going to be somebody who like studies these things and goes
in this direction. But now he he mixes more things in. There
was probably that time period where I started streaming where
the Israel Palestine stuff was something he was legitimately
focused on and was trying to make that work. That is far less
entertaining and I think he thought he has the barometer to go
do it right with his audience. So, I think I think that's just
way different. I think that's like a different approach that
basically he he's not sticking to now and he he wouldn't stick
to most of the time. >> I will get into clicking them a
lot because I'm like, "Wait, what happened?" I click on every
video is just a lie. They never ever deliver on the >> although
Yeah. I tingle Fringle Kesh actually points out that he still
does the tweeting and stuff at the same time. So, realistically,
he's applying the strategy just on different platforms. Like,
it is the same strategy applied, but he's not using his main
YouTube channel to do it at that point, >> the clickbait
title. So, but if he wants to do that, that's fine for his own
audience and for his career, but he's not doing it this way.
You know, being crazily edgy. >> Realistically, Destiny
could have juggled these things. So, somebody Well, he can't
juggle both of these things. Like, he's trying to do the edgy,
but also study lab leak theory. And people like don't like both
of those things in tandem, so he's shedding viewers. No, no,
no. I think he could do this. I think it's it's those things
and then um unfortunately all of the stuff with the with the
Pixie lawsuit, uh the Cherry the Cherry allegations, everything
everything that's going on with him, right? I think that stuff
actually causes you could do both and people would maybe drive
with both and just like you as the personality that connects
them, but then being like a total piece of [__] in
the background is also with him. He needs one of these things
to go right. That's including the Okay. Okay. Fair enough. Fair
enough. >> Going down that path. >> David Pacman
did do some tweet and I remember him complaining about how people
were trying to cancel him. That was kind of edgy and but I can't
remember what the tweet was. >> I remember that. >> Oh,
the uh it was about the mass the covenant school. The tweet by
David Pacman um caused significant controversy was posted on
March 27th, 2023 followed by a mash at the Coington School, a
Christian school in Nashville, >> Uh no, it hasn't only
surprising that there would be a match of a Christian school
given the lack of >> I would just say overall the the numbers
have been down. It seems like >> blamed for these horrible
events. Is it possible they weren't praying enough or correctly
um despite being a Christian school? Okay. >> Wow. You
know what? I'm glad you remember that cuz that is pretty [__]
>> That is that is sort of the almost exact kind of tweeting
was trying to go for but maybe even that up. Like I think he's
trying to do the same kind of messaging. So maybe you're right.
Maybe you just don't. >> Well, this is this is kind of
blaming the this is in the same ballpark, right? >> blaming
the kids. Blaming the dead kids. >> At least with No, I
think it's it's a bad it's a bad tweet. Um, but at least with
this one, you can understand the concept is something about complaint
because the left complains about the >> I didn't even I
wasn't listening close enough to hear Adam read the tweet. I'm
guessing that David Pacman did not also the children, right?
>> Like he could say, "Oh, those stupid." He could make
some joke about the kids, right? and dying. But did he also them
>> do [__] >> Probably not. >> Like
you can understand the through line of what he's trying to say.
The Destiny one it was like there is no through >> Yeah.
There was nothing there to grab onto. So >> but again this
is this is on the is there anything this tasteful this distasteful
on the right. >> I'm sure there's
>> some comment. Yeah. Yeah. Danny come. We can't be just
some name because recently the big topic was been so much about
immigration. There's been tons of distasteful comments about
immigration. I don't know if there have been dist about people
dying that I can think of. Oh that's hilarious. >> Sorry
people are insulting me on the super chats. They are getting
a funny. They are making funny jokes. >> Uh Michael from
$20 says >> I'm going to
style tweets. >> Where do we I'm going to I'm going to
find where we move forward on the clip again. Not that they're
not funny on their own. They are. But I'm going to wait for them
to actually get to There we go. >> I'll look him up. Maybe
I'll play.
We have to reach the Yes. The extremists will never reach. I'm
not talking about like the embedded mas will never
being herself is a perfect representative to reach out to the
>> retired. No. So clearly. >> Oh, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. like the embedded mangas who will never move. I'm
not talking about those >> Nattoart being herself is the
perfect representative to reach out to the
>> Oh, sorry. I didn't realize Adam was going to say that.
Arrow dart tired. >> No. So clearly >> Oh, the tweet.
Okay. So, I found was Yeah. Mike Lee tweeted out, you know, the
guy who
uh shot and
uh the the people in Minnesota, the Democrats in Minnesota. >> Like
the guy who pretended to be cop, you know, he wore that weird
mask that made him look kind of like
>> Yes. So, he tweeted out tweet out nightmare on Wall
Street with a picture of the guy right after, you know, three
people. So, >> so yeah, I would agree that's him people
being murdered. So, >> horrendous
impeachment. >> I You can make jokes about people if it's
funny enough, you can make jokes about people dying. Nobody disputes
this. I'm not saying don't reach out to people who are because
I do think most people are stupid and we do need to appeal to
stupid people. What I'm saying is we are not >> I just
stop saying most people are stupid. Such it makes you sound horrible.
You sound like soy pill. Okay. You sound like not so >> everyone
who doesn't watch our show is stupid. I listen that's what I
believe and I think it's just true. >> Uh would you talk
to Adam and Sitch again? Yeah, probably. Yep. Uh probably. I
think the last time I talked to any of them, Adam invited me
on the show and
for like personal reasons, I basically said I wasn't going to
go on that time. Um, it was to talk about some of Desty's allegations
and stuff and I just said I had some stuff going on personally
in real life and I was like, I can't make it, man. Sorry. Maybe
next time. >> Well, that's objectively true, but sometimes
you do say most people are >> And without
watch. Well, without the context that it's only the people who
don't watch the show, I think people might assume that you're
talking about most our audience. >> No, no, no, no. I would
never never burst our audience, our genius level >> Of
course. Yeah. Is does soy bill have cat ears on? Just something
about a guy wearing cat ears that says >> do not think
he has cat ears on. >> Everyone is stupid. >> I do
not think he he has a giant pickle in the background saying,
"Hey, there's >> He's a giant pickle Rick in the background."
And I think he's wearing a beanie. So, it's not >> Not
the good aesthetic.
There's some unambiguous like we can't really tell you how many
people this is releasing our own side. I'm not trying to cancel.
I'm not saying that you guys are bad, that nobody should support
you. I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying you would be more effect.
>> Dude, I uh I I have a habit of like highlighting messages
I'm reading in my side chat >> for myself and now when
I can click on them and highlight them on screen, it's just it's
going to get confusing. It'll take me a second to get used to
the standards that we say we care about. The right in large part
because they've forgotten to have principles. They don't have
them. They don't
Oh my god. >> He's gonna keep bringing it up. >> It's
insane. It's insane. >> It's not insane. You could just
be more specific. Like I think the thing that upsets Adam is
people aren't specific and they act like it's all conservatives
or because they're just lazy with the the labeling, right? If
you said, you know, like Trump adjacent people are totally principalists.
They are they're enriching themselves. There are mass corruption
things, mass corruption events happening right now. Like every
crypto startup that's happening right now is a mass corruption
event. It should not be happening. They're lightning uh they're
lightning regulations on crypto. They're probably going to the
crypto industry, right? Like the the come down on the crypto
industry after the Trump presidency is going to be so cataclysmic
that that they're actually going to destroy that industry, right?
People are going to be so soured on it that they will crush that
industry in America.
And it's not because of the crypto industry, which has its own
faults. It is because they are absolutely abusing it to run Ponzi
schemes and defraud the entirety of the American people or as
many Americans as they can. Right? That is the that is the issue.
It's not that crypto is inherently bad. It's not. It's it's that
they are allowing it to be used for abuses because they are allowing
themselves to abuse it >> and they fancy themselves just
the the arbiters of morality.
>> They're getting by the one principle that they held
which was around the Epstein files. It's them over when you hold
standards for yourself and then you fail the standards. The people
noticed the problem the Democrats had is multifaceted. Number
one, we pretended to have moral standards that we never gave
us going to the progressives. And number two, >> well,
that's true. That's 100% true. Cuz I mean, I think that's what
kind of woke you and I and a lot of other people up was the left
had the left seemed like they had the standard of free speech
and free ideas and, you know, pro jokes and pro art, pro science.
Yeah. >> Wick is cooking here. Wait, wait, wait. Wick is
talking in the chat or >> No, you're just saying which
quick is cooking with this panel. I got it. >> That's 100%
true cuz I mean I think that's what kind of woke you and I, you
know, pro jokes and pro art.
Pro science. Yeah. >> That's the one that really got me.
The pros science one. I was like I thought we were in favor of
science. >> No, there's infinite genders. >> Thank
you. >> When the leftists took over everything >> and
I've seen Wicked already. >> The standards that we do have,
which are good democratic standards, we are not always upholding
to. We need to be more clear about when we're upholding to them.
There are some people that we need to go over. But I am telling
you, Tees and Asmin Golds don't need scorched earth and neither
do tallies. >> Those are not the people
like winning some people over by by being uptight like we were
for 20 years. Like I didn't see this happen. There's literally
people in my comment section who say, "I would like to interject."
Thank you. >> I love how um not making fun of dead kids
is being uptight. Perfect framing. So there are people who come
into my comment section and they say, "Oh, I really like Steven
until >> So I think Tee backed out of a collab with not
so Aerodite um because of some comments Destiny made or that's
what Erodite was saying." And then I think Tech did end up collabing
with her anyway, which maybe we'll watch that later. We'll see.
>> And you know what X normally is? It's either the past
[__] week with the dead girls or it's Cory
>> What's that? >> Are you going to vote Trump? Now
you guys thank God I had that bullet. Okay, so I'm just laughing
at it. Well, and by the way, well, actually, hold on. This brings
up a previous point. So, you were saying that like, "Oh, it's
just jokes. It's just jokes." And actually, that Soy Pills probably
brought it up more than anybody else saying like, "Oh, you're
trying to police our jokes. You're trying to police our jokes."
Uh, excuse me. Correct me if I'm wrong because this is the malice
that most people are identifying. Is the fact that you and I
both genuinely believe that MAGA is a quasi fascist movement
that doesn't care about the rule of law, the Republic of the
United States, or its people.
>> Yes. And that's why
the just to be clear, the what aboutism on like Donald Trump's
evil thing is how you get Donald Trump in the first place, right?
Just to be clear with everybody, that's how that's how critical
theory got these people onto like the Trump train and and remaining
on it over time, right? Like basically you can go, well, yeah,
Trump's like totally defrauding the American people. He's like
totally running a bunch of schemes, a bunch of like uh what would
you call it? Like Ponzi schemes to get himself rich and enrich
his family. He's totally he's like the most corrupt president
ever. But the Democrats are so you you can't just abandon all
moral standards for everybody you you hold near and dear because
the other side are really bad. That's like that's an insane >> You
don't care that Cory Compatory or whatever his thing name is
is wittingly or unwittingly he's effectively supporting fascism.
That doesn't that apply to the left though that MAGA is a >> You
could say it's a a socialist >> Here it is. A quasi >> a
quasi fascist >> fascist movement that doesn't care about
the rule of law, the republic of the United States or its people.
I mean that's that's basically the left now. It's exactly what
they are. They hate America. They hate America. They hate
They hate rule of law as long as it stands in their way of achieving
their socialist utopia. What's the problem? Why are they Look,
>> yeah, go ahead. Go ahead. >> I was going to say
that's the problem is that I that's why I feel like we both we're
in the the hell zone right here because we have the the socialists
that have a lot of sway over the left, which yes, don't care
about rule of law, hate America, want to destroy everything.
And then you have Trump who personally Trump does not rule of
law whatsoever. And most of his >> I like watching Adam
and Z sometimes because when it's just them that you can turn
them up to like 1.5, 1.75 and understand them perfectly. They're
um I don't think that's like a there's not a negative commentary
on them. They just uh they speak like slowly and deliberately.
So I don't mind turning off, but most of the supporters they
don't care about rule or any of the protections that you know
the right has historically cared about whenever they felt the
left was infinity on the right. All that stuff goes out the window
in order to affect whatever you know deporting a billion people
or whatever it is that Trump wants to do. >> Yeah. Most
people care about winning or initiating some policy proposal
that they like over the rule of law, right? Following the rules,
>> right? I think that's pretty standard. But the the problem
that I have is when >> people on the left come out and
say, "Oh, yeah, it's just the right that has that problem." Not
acknowledging the fact that they don't care about law either
if it comes to accomplishing whatever goal it is they want to
>> Well, I'm assuming Connor wouldn't say that because
Connor still, I believe, identifies as on the right and he on
the left a lot. So, I'm assuming he would agree with that. That's
both sides. >> So, he's coming at it from our perspective,
but just center right instead of center left. >> Yes. Yes.
We all care about the law. the law. As long as >> as long
as a law allows us to incarcerate Nazo Ariodite, then we care,
right? We're cringe.
>> And that's why you don't care that Cory Compatory or
whatever his thing name is is wittingly or unwittingly. He's
effectively supporting fascism. >> Who's this person? I
have another >> It's the fire
rally and Butler. >> I care that a person died. I care
that right now when Medicaid gets shut down, the red states are
going to be hurting the most. It's it's a little bit like, well,
you voted for this, but like I care that people are >> Do
you care that Cory died? >> You can joke about it. >> Cory,
do you care? Stephen, do you care that Cory died? >> Why
is mad when people die? I don't want any milk over it. I mean,
>> like, okay, I understand you guys don't like the the
whole thing. Wait, do you guys get mad if if somebody says like
Hassan and his movement hate America and they're like trying
to destroy that they support such anti-American policies? Do
you guys get mad at that or are you guys like totally fine when
when people make that argument about Hassan without just saying
the left overall? I'd just be curious where like the consistency
is there because I think a lot of people are totally fine with
with pointing at Hassan and saying he hates America. People around
him hate America and they support anti-American policies because
they are like they they don't like America. They they hate us.
We shouldn't include them in anything. I don't think you could
say that it's stupid for Sitch and Adam to make that comment
when they're clearly going to be like talking about Hassan, right?
Like that is probably the primary person they're talking about
in those cases. Not Destiny, but Hassan >> a little bit.
Yeah. Okay. >> Oh my god,
>> that's so bad. That's so bad.
>> It's funny. >> God, I just Okay, whatever. It's
funny. They're talking about the firefighter that guy gets in
front of his kids. >> It's fair to say about Hassan that
I don't think you guys think these guys are as when they make
that comment as you let on. >> which is obviously >> which
is a riot. It's totally hilarious. And I don't think most and
this is a problem too like you know a lot of most people that
vote for Trump but most of them voted for Harris like I don't
think they they're not thinking like >> why why is Shu
on head a moderator in their chat the what is this sing from
oh look it's shoon she can be a mod she can be come on guys come
on dude oh I want fascism or socialism or whatever in the country
that's that's not what they're thinking I don't think that >> mod
equals VIP >> is like yes I'm supporting a fascist I don't
think that's a thought >> of course not of course not >> if
there are that are like, "Yes, I'm full-blown fascist. I support
fascism." Or, "I'm full-blown communist. I support communism
in your country." And they die. Like, I'm not going to go about
those people. But I don't think that's 99% of the people in America
that vote are participating in these >> Yeah, that's the
problem cuz it's just it's kind of a faceless person. You don't
know much about him. But I do think they tried to dig into him
to try to find an excuse to >> Yeah, I hit some problematic
tweets, I believe. I don't remember. >> So, they're like,
"Oh, this guy's a racist or whatever." They were a racist. I
don't know. I don't know the exact timeline, but I'm pretty sure
that it was after the fact that Destiny was on him for dying
that they're like, "Well, well now it's we got to dig into his
tweets to find something bad about it." >> I'm just not
that type of person. Okay. I've been making a lot of jokes about
not so I've been making a lot of jokes about Destiny. I don't
want to see Destiny in front of his kid. Okay. I'm not going
to think that's funny. >> I'm not going to like people
in our audience might come to us and think that's funny. And
I'm just I'm not I'm not one of those types of people. Like I'm
just >> That's like just a normal That's a normal human
being take. Okay. >> I'm not going to go there. Even if
I hate the person, right? >> There's some level of decency.
>> This is how we feel about Willy Knock. It's like we
we hate that guy. We don't like that guy at all. I don't want
like his wedding ruined or something. I have no dude. It's like
internet beef. That That's so stupid. >> See, we need to
maintain. It's just not good. Right. I don't like the
>> Yeah, I agree. >> Yeah. Locking nacho area died
up on a weekend. Now, that would be >> what
what the what the wait what what are you saying right now, Adam?
I kid. I kid. Come on. Well, unless it's like a DUI or something,
then obviously throw her in the jail. Throw in the clink. >> But
yeah, you can make a joke about it and it could be absolutely
funny. 100%. >> So, why can't we make a joke about roll
that back? We should roll that back. >> Yeah. Locking area
died up on a weekend. Now, that would be I can't >> Oh,
like like Okay. I think he's saying like on some minor thing
getting her thrown in like jail and then her not being able to
process until the Monday. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Not being able to
get processed until the Monday. That would be funny. >> I
kid. Come on. Well, unless it's like a DUI or something. Throw
her in the jail. Throw in the clink. >> Well, yeah, you
can make a joke about it and it could be absolutely funny. 100%.
>> So, why can't we make a joke about that? There is an
underlying denying >> point less unhinged than I thought.
That's funny.
>> The October 7th stuff, right, when Hamas came in about
all those. It's funny, >> Yeah, you can. I just expect
people to be off about it and stop supporting you >> What
was the Wait, what was the Do you think somebody here to say
we can't joke >> Well, no. >> No. Wait, hold on.
Wait. So, do you think we can make jokes about you okay with
that? >> I would never make a joke about a prison. That's
not my thing. >> I make a Holocaust cover.
Yeah, of course. Obviously. >> Hold on. Do you think that
the people making jokes about it? >> This whole thing about
the This has never come up in the conversation. I think it's
very important. This whole thing about jokes is completely off
center. It's completely misguided because originally when people
were complaining about >> [__] hold on. Is
there something wrong with my um Hold on. Uh-oh. Uhoh. One
>> The left and the woke crowd coming for people for jokes.
It really was you had like a comedian who, you know, maybe they
have some political feelings, but they weren't going on stage
giving some sort of political message. They were just telling
jokes in all directions at all people. And then people on the
left would say, "You're not allowed to do that. You can only
make jokes against white people and white."
>> Apparently, my Discord account just got perma suspended.
Uh, what does it say? Oh, okay. That seems insane. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Okay, this Dude, this is Hold on.
I Hold on, dude. Hold on. I just have to show you guys what my
Discord This is This is, by the way, like the kind of brigading
that happens in our Discordage. Okay, hold on. Let me show you.
Let me show you what I just got uh perma for. Okay, I just got
perma for child safety. Oh, hold on. Child safety for this comment.
Apparently, that is a child safety comment that I just got perma.
My my account got perma for child safety. Is vouch a child? Is
vouch a child? Like, this is not even remotely close. Yeah, I
straight up didn't I didn't violate this policy at all. Nope,
I didn't violate the policy. Hold on. Cuz I just got logged out
of all of my So hold on because I need to I need to take care
of this really quickly. Yeah,
Bosch is Bosch is straight up not a child. So I don't I just
don't understand it. Can you appeal a perma ban? You can. You're
on the Discord right now. I am not.
I'm not I'm not I'm not. Anyway, we're back. >> And men,
if you're making a joke that's critical of someone who's a protected
class or on the left or minority, you're not allowed to do that.
Okay. That's what the whole like you're not allowed to make jokes
was about. It was literally people not from a political context
were not allowed to make jokes about specific classes or groups
of >> And now it's and it's annoying me because now it's
being shifted in this, you know, Destiny people. They're not
comedians. Not people are just making equal opportunity jokes
everyone. They're like, "Oh, I just want to >> Z's owner
again." I actually don't know how that works. Does anyone know
how that works when you get permo from Discord? Is that uh second
in command on the Discord would be BB Poison? So, I'm not totally
sure what happens.
He's got like the second highest roll ranking or
I I totally trust him to like hand stuff back to me. So >> to
be able to say like really offensive, horrendous things for a
specific political purpose to dehumanize the my enemies my political
enemies and say I thought legal that's a completely different
argument that was not really part of the conversation from the
>> Uh Oofi Keller thing for the 14 months.
>> Guys, if you like the content, um I I have an alt Archandriel,
but I'm just not going to log into it right now. I absolutely
have an alt. It's just goofy as that's all. Um,
what happened with Vosch? I got reported on Discord for child
endangerment over the uh this comment. Vosch is not a child.
There's no child thing here. What are we talking about?
What are we talking about? Although, was that comment today?
Yeah, that comment was today. Rhox, um,
why are people talking? cuz there's a Vosch thing where like
somebody there's a Sarah Fields tweet where Vosch apparently
talked to somebody.
>> any case, awesome sauce. Thank for the five gifted.
Let's go. Are these automatically triggered? I I think they're
borderline automatically triggered. So yeah.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Br people to their side or push
them >> Yeah. No wait. Is there an undercurren of malice?
This is relevant. Is there an undercurren of malice within the
joke? >> Yeah. It was the policy. It's not the fact that
people like or whoever the are making jokes about why they actually
legitimately 100% support. That's a big
>> That's why people are because they actually think that
you don't give a when conservatives die because they're the own.
That's literally
really thought that God smited those girls for with Seriously.
No, they think about
you think they think that you >> did you see that? That
was such an interesting height defense mechanism in place here
because obviously it's undeniable that people would look at and
Destiny's I assume is not so understand this is that people on
the right would look at that tweet and assume that Destiny honestly
believes that he's that he's totally fine with children dying
and people dying as long as they support >> and then he
twists that around to well obviously that's stupid. Do you think
people think that I honestly thought God did it? It's like that
wasn't what anyone was talking about. What are what the [__]
are you smoking? >> Yeah. There's an underlying malice
that you legitimately do not give a [__] about these
kids. And I'm pretty sure I heard that you don't give a [__]
about these cuz I'm pretty sure you said you don't give a [__]
>> I just I'm just tired of Bailey.
>> Yes, there is. You're doing it. You're doing it over
and over again. I am saying being mean loses the middle and then
you >> Oh, see now that I now going to change the topic
and give Destiny the amount cuz I did want him to answer that
question that Connor was posing. Is he not care if children die
if they're MAGA? If their parents are MAGA go, so you just want
us to be nice and not meet mean jokes. No, the way you're being
is alienating people to your effect like
It's a double-edged sword because it's alienating some people,
but obviously the Destiny fans want him to say he doesn't care
if MAGA kids die. >> Of course. >> Yeah, that's the
appeal for them.
>> It's Vos's damage, too. >> I don't know if this
would be like an intentional tendy testing. Maybe it's just sort
of an unconscious thing. >> If Destiny's trying to kind
of like grow out his audience, he there's like a huge swath of
the left online that are very far left that are socialist who
would probably be anti- Destiny because Destiny for a long time
was also very anti-ocialist, anti-woke. And maybe the only way
to appeal to them to bring them back is he can't really do a
heel turn on on the far left, but he can just be as, you know,
sociopathically anti-ight as possible. And maybe that will draw
those people back in the crowd, but be willing to forgive Destiny
for being antisocialist if he's as, you know, cruel and crazy.
What is the M and Bailey? Do I need to know? The Mott and Bailey
that I think Erdite's proposing here is the Mott is is like you're
making a joke about dead kids and then the Bailey is like is
this is actually a criticism of Greg Abbott or some fund some
town like denying relief funds for some disaster, right? I think
so >> against the right as they would want. >> You
think that's what he's trying? >> It's possible cuz how
else would you attract those people? You've already burned the
socialist bridge. >> And we're going to see if he'll turn
on the socialism soon here, aren't we? Destiny's going to be
like, "Oh, maybe maybe there's something to this socialism thing."
He's going to do a live stream with Bosch, a big makeup live
stream. >> Vos, you've convinced me. >> Well, I think
I think he's so um fixated on Trump as as being the root cause
of all the bad things that I seems like I think he would have
if he thought it would help hurt the Trump movement or destroy
the Trump movement. Yeah, he would have aligned with the socialist
side of things. Yes. >> I just I think it's all audience.
I don't think he gives a about the sides or the politics or anything.
>> No, I I I don't just I'm not sure I >> Hold on.
Did Adam just get that right? I think Adam might have just gotten
that >> I think it's all audience. I don't think he gives
a [__] about the sides or the politics or anything.
>> No, I I I
saw him back. >> He got it. >> I still used to watch
him. He did become increasingly agitated and more and more angry
at Trump and the re >> uh sweaty sweater. I've not covered
that content yet. I don't know if I'm going >> Trumpy of
the And I do think it kind of brain broke him. >> So I
I think it's I think it's a legitimate feeling from him. >> Which
hypocrisy in particular? Was it the what is it? What's the hypocrisy
on the right that brain broke him? I think from him, if I recall
correctly, it would be that he felt like he was going out of
his way to be nicer to people in the past and then that they
there would be this or I think I'm trying to remember cuz he
went over this so it's been a long time. I haven't been watching
content for a while. I think a lot of it was about the sort of
the right adopting the kind of cancel culture mentality of the
left of if you were not a Trump supporter, you'd be instantly,
you know, exised and annihilated and attacked pretty very viciously
when they were supposed to decide that was anti- cancel culture.
>> Right-wingers canceling other right on the right. The
one that the thing that brain broke him. >> I think that
was part of it. I just >> I think it was it was the lack
of the rule of law. The right had been so big on rule of law
for so long and basically throwing down the trash can as long
as Trump's doing it or it's you know bad
>> I don't buy any of it. >> I'm just ask what I
interpreted when I was watching his content back in >> I
mean he he came across even the January 6 stuff which he became
obsessed with. He came across super late in the game like two
years after we did. Why wasn't he interested while it was happening?
We were we totally were >> we were attention. It was around
the time period, if you remember, this was like around a time
period where also the Supreme Court was granting Trump immunity
that he started freaking out about everything, really thinking
that Trump was going to become a dictator if he won the election.
>> Yeah. For audience share, not because he really cared.
>> Maybe maybe it was all cynical. Maybe it's all for a
share. I I interpreted as legitimate fear. I don't think it's
I'm not saying I agree with his view. I'm saying I I think that
his feeling about it was how he actually felt about it. I don't
think it was just for his >> Do you think he really has
TDS? >> Oh, yeah. I don't think it's like a play for the
audience. >> I think it is. >> Okay. I don't think
about maybe I mean just the I see >> I mean it's fine I'm
I'm far too much in the other direction. I'm far too much in
the direction. I think most people are either lying to themselves
or sincere. >> there is there is a consistency I mean we've
been we've been live streaming together for quite some time and
there's just there's a consistency to our behavior and our personalities
that >> So I'm just trying to get uh some something going
so I could view the Discord basically. Just give me a second.
Not interacting or anything. I just need to be able to view the
Discord so I can see uh what's going on there. That's all. We're
good. We're good. >> There's a through line there. I I
don't see that with Destiny. Like he seems all over the place.
>> I don't agree. I He's I mean Hear is a person who was
very hyperaggressive,
unhinged, massively narcissistically
>> And then he got a little bit better and then he went
back to being that again. So I know to me it's like he's more
like returning to who he was. >> Oh, he got a little bit
better when he did the I'm going to reach out to moderates and
stuff like that. >> To me, that was like the whole I'm
trying to do things for my audience. >> And then he's a
then he's a return to form. So he's he's the whole time he's
hanging out with um with Nick Fuentes, he's suppressing his hatred
for Donald
>> Has he always had I I just maybe I wasn't watching in
2016. I don't know that he's always had TDS.
>> I mean I don't remember what when it >> Like Sam
Harris I' I've seen a consistent level of TDS from Sam Harris.
>> Yeah. But not necessarily from Destiny. It just seems
like Destiny is a >> his job is to follow trends and to
do things that are going to garner him attention. So I just I
don't see any sincerity in that whatsoever. >> Maybe
I jump a little bit. >> And then they voted [__]
right in the last election.
Yes, I understand. Why did the left them up and not the right?
>> What? Why did the left them off but the right didn't
when the right is so aggressive on
minorities? Not >> nobody's arguing about edy jokes. So
I feel congrats. I I do think that's a bad argument from Connor
cuz it's not oh they want to tell jokes about minorities. It's
like no people wanted people were sick of of being attacked because
of their race because they're white because of their gender because
they're male and then being told well you're a bad person if
you don't you know self flagagillate and adhere to whatever the
hyper progressive insane doctrine is because they wanted to tell
jokes about minorities. >> Put uh pronouns in your bio.
>> They objected to being subjug. >> You guys still
use the terms TDS me. Um, yeah. I mean, it's pretty that's one
of those terms that like, yeah, you know, raises the hair on
your arms. Sure, I >> It's a little weird to use it when
realistically you should probably >> pretty deranged about
Trump. >> Oh, there's no such thing as gender. It's not
biological. You can be any kind of farting fancical uniform you
want to believe. It's just people there's a bridge too far. And
the left was in that direction. The right's not. It's weird because
it's very different. Like with Trump, the bridge too far isn't
ideology. It's just it's it's sort of like the way in which you
manifest the ideology. So it's almost from a completely different
perspective. The left was we're going to go too far in terms
of like telling you what you have to believe. And the Trump stuff
is like well you only have to believe in like not having illegal
immigrants or something in the country, right? That's not that's
not an unhinged belief. But then it's like okay what are you
what are you willing to overlook essentially? >> That's
that's basically the like I think Sitch when he talks about this
stuff is he's speaking to like what the average person wants,
right? He's not speaking to what's like the most intelligent
or best position to have. He's saying this is what the average
person is saying. This is like how they feel. It's like a very
different thing to be talking about >> or how how much
how many crypto scams is Donald Trump allowed to do? How many
FC files is Donald Trump allowed to to bury to to get that goal?
>> He's freeing crypto from the cringe. What are you talking
about? Don't you know the line? >> Of course. Of course.
>> See, I look I hate all of that stuff obviously, but
it's just I'm not going to go unhinged about Donald Trump. I
got more important things in my life to focus on. So, and I think
people do focus too much on politics. >> No, that's that's
fine. But as long as you have the same level of feeling, I guess,
about that towards, you know, the woke left or trans issues or
some other cuz then otherwise then it's like, well, why would
why does that bother you? But this other stuff that Trump's doing
is just doesn't bother you. >> The the Well, I mean, obviously
you have to go issue by issue. The reason the trans stuff really
bothers me is because it affects every single parent in America,
right? Crypto stuff doesn't affect every single parent in America.
I guess you could make the argument it does and that their kid
might get some crypto, but I think that's a manageable problem
compared to the I think I'm transgender false positive fallout.
No, that makes sense. >> It's like a hugely different situation,
>> Why are you guys question marking what he's saying?
>> He's he's explaining to you why a voter would not care
about the crypto stuff, which is just true because if it wasn't
true, then there would be riots all across America right now.
You understand that, right? You could get really mad at Adam
and say he's like a total [__] but obviously if people
cared about the crypto stuff, if they cared about the corruption
and they they were like hearing these facts and they cared about
it, then there would be riots all over the place cuz Trump's
obviously been corrupt. He's been going insane self uh enriching
himself, right? >> Like if >> he's explaining his
own feelings. >> Why does that bother you? But this other
stuff that Trump's doing is just doesn't bother you. >> The
the Well, I mean, obviously you have >> I don't know if
he has family >> issue by issue. The reason the trans stuff
really bothers me is because it affects every single parent in
America, right? Crypto stuff. >> Oh, he's saying, okay,
he is saying how he feels, but he's saying it affects every parent
in America. I assume I assume when I hear this that he's talking
about like how those people >> Doesn't affect every single
parent in America. I guess you could make the argument it does
and that their kid might get some crypto, but I think
he's giving like I don't know why you would have this as your
way of engaging with issues. Sorry. I'm like, oh, it makes sense
that he would think, oh, not every parent cares. That makes sense
to me. If he's going to say his his barometer for what issues
he cares about or what parents care about, then I don't understand.
I don't understand why that doesn't make any sense to me at all.
>> Compared to the I think I'm transgender false positive.
>> No, that makes sense. >> It's like a hugely different
situation, >> I sorry, he is answering the question I'm
talking about. He's explaining why it's like a bad why it's bad
optically. He's not explaining his own feelings at all. He's
literally using other people's feelings to explain why he thinks
it's like important or not important.
I don't know. He just didn't engage with what Sitch actually
said, even though he said he was going to, >> Like if Trump
came out and said, "Look, um, one of my kids is transgender."
Like, I would be like, "What the >> Because it's going
to really that's going to affect a lot of people." So, >> no,
that that does make sense. Um, I think that's fair. The way that
I look at it is >> I am baffled. I'm very baffled at that
whole exchange. If you have a president,
>> he doesn't he doesn't have kids. I'm very baffled at
what's going on there.
>> Play things where, you know, a lot of rich crypto people
will just pay Trump a bunch of money and invest in >> I'm
not saying he's not be very vivic. I'm saying that he is I'm
telling you that that is true that most parents don't care about
Trump doing the crypto stuff because they would much rather care
about the the transcript. That's how they view things. If he's
saying that, that is true. But I don't know why you would make
the fact that that is true your barometer for evaluating an issue,
right? That doesn't make any sense to me. >> His cryptocoin
and then, you know, he'll drop he'll get the justice department
to drop investigations into those people and he'll, you know,
get the justice department or he'll get the, you know, the regulators
to stop regulating crypto and all this other stuff. Um, to me
it's like, okay, if a person you need kids of your own to care
about it. No, you don't. You don't. But it's like literally you're
not describing your own interests. I would say probably a base
level theory of all of Adam's political engagement is people
argue for things that are within their own interest. He does
not have an interest here. Right? And I do believe that probably
you would argue that setting the precedent and he's smart enough
to engage with this. I assume that setting the precedent where
government officials and explicitly the president are allowed
to enrich themselves with no downside does affect your kids.
Absolutely it does. So like that's not even remotely that's just
like maybe the worst justification I've ever heard >> is
is willing to enrich themselves financially like that in such
a blatantly corrupt way. I don't know why you would trust them
to do anything because obviously that person is highly corrupt.
They're going to do whatever good point >> and then the
fact that people >> that if they're going to engage in
this kind of corruption then they're not trustworthy on any issue
>> kind of or overlook it to me. I kind of view that as
similar to the whole way of of what you're talking about with
like >> look at look at sitch cooking >> the trans
issue affecting all parents is if as a culture we basically say
well it's okay for the president to just scam and to take money
and to do paperflation to generate >> he just hit every
point he just hit every massive W's for he just hit every point
he just hit every single point >> you know corrupt immoral
things >> let's go >> just hand that away I think
that's massively degenerating our culture in our the moral fabric
of America >> well you're kind of making a different argument
here though argument yeah >> you're saying that you're
saying that Trump is the crypto thing points to a corruption
in Trump that Trump will only do things that are self- serving,
right? >> He's very willing to. Yes. >> Okay. I see
it completely differently. I see it as the same as I see the
transgender issue on the left. I think Trump sees it as a win-win.
Like I think he thinks this is going to enrich me. It's also
going to make a lot of other people rich who are in the crypto
game and it's going to help a lot of kids. >> Wick's engaging
a lot in this chat. Let's see. >> They're going to make
money. Everyone's going to make money. Win win.
They on the left. The left is not looking at it as oh
>> position on doxing is dox is okay if it's people I hate
like queen/ shtock it's bad if I like them wait did I miss them
starting this conversation cuz this guy just came in baldick
straw person okay and he started talking about me and
did I miss chats from before this were talking about doxing and
stuff let me see I'm just going to back it up just a little bit
and see if there was chats about doxing and I don't see it I
don't see it so we'll see if that's just oh Destiny will flip-flop
constantly look at what he said about consent versus his current
actions with Pixie. Also, his position on doxing changed too.
Oh, there we go. There's the first one.
And then we get keep going. We keep going. Maybe true Kiki Lee.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Okay, we'll keep >> They're thinking
this is a massive win. We're changing society for the better.
It's good for us. It's going to be good for us politically and
it's going to be good for all these kids because they're going
to catch their transition early and they're going to be able
to transition and pass. Win-win win. So, neither side is really
corrupt. I mean, and a lot of people a lot of people on the right
do frame it as corrupt. They're like, "Adam, you're so naive.
You they want to destroy society by destroying the gender uh
binary. That's what they're trying to do. They're trying to do
it to destroy society." And I'm like, "No, that's not really
what's happening here." >> I understand what they So, cuz
yeah, I'm not to be clear, I'm not really talking I wasn't really
talking about when I talk about corruption, maybe it's my own
fault. I'm not really talking about like motivations the way
that you're talking about. So, thank God I defended Adam there
and then dude the idea that sorry just his r that doesn't make
sense as a way to decide things that that's like actually just
populism
but populism for parents when you're not a parent. I just pick
whatever issue I decide how right or wrong something is based
on how what percentage of parents in America would agree with
me. That's I'm having a hard time even taking it remotely seriously.
Um, I think that you can be corrupt by either being a person
who says, "Yes, you give me money and I will do something good
for you." I think that is corrupt and I assume you agree with
that. And but I also say if you can convince yourself that something
is a win-win sit >> parents vote. Yes, parents vote. But
you're saying I want to do the popular >> that just happens
to benefit you financially because people lie themselves first
and foremost. I'd say that that's just as corrupt. I don't to
me I'm not going to make a distinction if you can. >> And
he's by the way and he's just explicitly stated the rationale
for being against the reason all parents would be against transgender
stuff. a bunch of parents think, "Yeah, they're trying to destroy
the gender binary with America and with my kids." And he's like, "No,
I don't think that's what's happening." Right? So, he just said
the actual rationale that those parents would use is something
he actually disagrees with. Brain break yourself or mind yourself
or you're Eric Hartman and you can like you're so narcissistically
egotistical that you can lie to yourself so effectively that
you can convince yourself that what you're doing is right or
justified. I don't think that that absolves someone of of being
called >> Real quick, real quick. He said in comparison
to crypto, right? He was saying he wasn't really I mean the crypto
issue was there. He was saying, "I understand the trans issue
affecting parents more." Which is fair, but the crypto issue
does as well. And and Sitch laid out the reasoning, but that's
another reason. Listen, it works. Okay? That's why it works cuz
Adam says the thing and then Sitch gets to come back with the
actual good points. >> So there's a So there's a you're
baking a truth factor into the corruption that I don't think
most people will. Most people will like most people say lying.
It's not lying if you actually believed it even though it wasn't
actually correct. No, but there's a there's a spectrum of of
people thinking something and just being mistaken and people
convincing themselves of a lie that they should know, a reasonable
person would know is not accurate, right? Do you agree that there's
a difference between those two things? >> It it depends
upon the the use case. Obviously, in the crypto situation, it's
so complicated that Trump probably does believe he's helping
the universe. >> I could Okay, we'll use something easier
like with the Epstein files. I could 100% believe that Donald
Trump
himself into thinking that anytime his name comes up in Epste
files, it's just the evil Democrats planting evidence. Even if
in reality it all is true, whatever it says files about him is
all 100% true and he just forgot or you know whatever whatever
kind of mental gymnastics he's putting himself through or for
the greater good of the country, he's going to make up this lie,
right? >> The files is a much better example, >> right?
So I would say that that's I'd say even if even if Donald Trump
can like Eric Cartman lied to himself enough about the files,
that's still corrupt. doesn't matter to me, you know, whether
he's able to convince himself of that the action is morally.
>> This is not inconsistent with what Adams believed in
the past because Adam basically argued around January 6th that
Trump really thought he won the election. So like realistically,
he's not corrupt. >> Justified to bring up a Thanos mind
himself into thinking he was morally justified in half the universe,
but he's was action is still an evil action. Like it doesn't
change to me the how I'm going to describe the action,
>> That's why it's the same thing with the trans stuff.
I agree with you. I don't think I think that most of the people
that are pushing this trans stuff, they think they've mind themselves.
They've brain broken themselves into thinking that they're doing
some good thing. And I still say, well, those people, they need
to have some level of free will. They need to have some level
of self-control to realize that their own biases are have them
and they're creating these horrible negative outcomes in society.
So, just as I said that about the people pushing the trans stuff,
I said about Donald Trump and the whatever he's pushing with
crypto or the files or any other >> Well, why do you give
Destiny out then? >> don't Why would I When did I give
Destiny out? >> Cuz you you say he um he sincerely believes
this stuff. like his TDS is sincere. Just because he minded himself
into a TDS does
>> No. Well, I'm not g Okay, hold on. There's some confu
there's some confusion here. Sometimes, okay, sometimes when
there's a conversation where people say, "Oh, I think a person
really believes something." People interpret that as you saying
that they're like white or justified. That is not at all what
I was saying in that conversation with Destiny at all about his
his flavor of TDS. What I'm saying is you were making the argument
that you think that it's fake. His anger, his outrage towards
Trump is fake based on him trying to grow an audience. And I'm
saying no, I think he really feels that way. I'm not saying it's
justified or good that he feels way. I'm saying I think he does
feel that way. That doesn't You understand? I'm not saying it's
like a good thing. >> Yeah. No, I get it. I get it. I'm
just kind of trying to work out. There's kind of three states
of being here that we're putting some sort of emphasis on. There's
like the true belief
this is what you believe. You don't really have a dog in the
fight, you know, no reason to be biased or whatever, right? >> Obviously,
it's that there's no moral claim or easy >> to be in this
camp, right? How far is it from the earth to the sun, right?
Just who cares, right? um we can know it and believe it and it
it can all be true >> and then there is something that
we'd like to be true because we have some sort of vested interest
in it and maybe it's not really true but we've mind that's a
term you keep using right you've convinced yourself that it is
true right >> and then there is the I know this is completely
untrue but it's in my interest to pretend that it is true and
I'm going to lie I know I'm lying I'm telling you something completely
different right I you know this is a case where you know you've
murdered your ex-girlfriend or something and you're like of course
I didn't do it cuz if someone finds out you're going to get in
trouble You don't you're not you don't believe you know you're
lying. Right. >> You're not believe you're not believing
something. So what do you want to call the middle state? Like
trueish belief. There's like true belief. There's like how about
beliefing
>> Okay. So um I guess and the question that we're all
playing this game with everyone. It's like who is the liar? Who
is the true believer? And who is the believer? Right. >> Let's
go back to the crypt thing for example. Okay. >> I have
no idea. Sorry. I I almost want to escape this loop. Agree >> cuz
I have no idea why >> making decisions based on what they
think is good for the country overall and not necessarily what's
good for themselves uh as an individual or good for their right.
>> Yeah. This is why most people like judges and stuff
recuse themselves whenever there's a situation where there's
going to be a conflict of interest, right? >> Or you know
remember and this happened in Trump's first terms was like generally
when someone becomes president they would if they had any like
financial stakes and things they would get rid of them so that
they would seem like they'd have conflict of interest with anything.
Donald Trump famously didn't do that. He just said, "Oh, my children
will take control of it." And then they put all his children
in government as rest. >> Lots of people believe they are
above a conflict of interest. They think, "Look, I'm the magnanimous
person. I can't be
>> Yeah. Donald Trump is definitely in that camp, right?
>> I don't think so. >> Do you think the Epstein
stuff will be enough uh finally be enough to bury Trump? Uh I
think Trump's going to come up with another conspiracy for how
this happened and some people will buy. It won't be enough to
bury him. That's my my thoughts basically. There'll be like another
conspiracy. It'll be this this thing he's doing will be like
bought by people. It's Do you think Donald Trump thinks he's
capable of bias? >> I don't think he cares. >> Oh,
okay. Interesting. >> I don't think Donald Trump walks
around like making sure. I do not believe for a second that when
Donald Trump is thinking about anything, he has a little voice
in his head that says, "I have to make sure that I'm not being
biased and that my belief is based on something objectively true."
Correct. >> I don't think that thought even occurs to him.
>> If we if we asked Donald Trump, are there situations
where you could be biased? We both know the answer would be,
"Of course not." >> Oh, of course, you know, I
ask it person to be clear. If you ask >> it's already conservatives
online. Yeah, but I mean Lucas Jed, that's that's it's very funny.
If you see somebody who's like uh big, okay, we watch this happen
with Destiny unironically. There'll just be people who are opportunists
and they'll like take this opportunity where Trump's done something
wrong. And there's people like Cash Patel who are like invested
and they probably have to sit well maybe not Cash Patel actually
not Cash Patel there are people who are oh no yeah probably about
Cash Patel where he has to or Dan Bangino where he's like oh
this has really put me in a bad position he's like about it right
but there are also a whole bunch of people who will see this
as a new opportunity to ingratiate themselves to Trump to forgive
him for this openly and just take the risk right
like they will just ingratiate themselves openly they don't care
about the Epstein they'll just ingratiate themselves to him openly
and try to like take his side entirely. That's probably how Cash
Patel like this would have been during Crossfire Hurricane, right?
That's basically how Cash Patel ingratiated himself to Trump
in the first place is Trump would have had some scandal and Cash
Patel would have been like, "Oh yeah, look, I'm going to fully
defend this guy everywhere I can. I'm going to write this children's
book. I'm going to totally suck this guy's and then eventually
gets rewarded for it, right? Trump loves that. Trump loves rewarding
those people."
That question, every person will give you an answer. What I'm
saying is most people cannot just talk about most people when
they think of something. By the way, that's why populism is bad
because obviously uh Trump doesn't have any any devotion or any
investment in America actually, right? He doesn't care. And so
he will take somebody like Cash Patel who's shown him loyalty
over the country and he will promote them to one of the highest
stations in law enforcement because he doesn't care about the
country. He doesn't care about, you know, meritocracy in any
way. He just cares about people who suck his dick. >> They
assume their thought is correct. They're not like, "Oh, I need
to check my thought to make sure I'm not being biased." That's
not the way most people think. I sure you and I would both accept
that. You and I would both if you asked us, we would say, "Of
course I can be biased. I'm a human being." Obviously, everyone
is biased, right? It'd be a completely different answer. >> Yes.
Most people are going to say yes. >> But the question is
when you ask Donald Trump and he says, "Of course I'm incapable
of bias. I am the magnanimous Trump." Um,
>> what category is he? Again, I didn't say >> I
just want to know what category is he. Is he in the true belief?
Is he in the belief? Or is he does he know he's >> Uh,
I don't know. I could believe either of them. >> Any of
them? >> I guess it's Yeah, you're right. It's hard to
tell. Okay. >> But I want to bring up the crypto example.
Okay. So they both agree the president should be doing things
that are good for the country, not for them, not for themselves
specifically. So in 2019, Donald Trump tweets out, "I'm not a
fan of Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies, which are not money,
whose value is highly volatile and unregulated crypto assets
and facilitate unlawful behavior, including drug trade and other
illegal activities. We have only one real currency in the United
States, and it is stronger than ever. Both dependable and reliable."
>> But then he wanted the libertarians. >> Is by
far the most dominant currency anywhere in the world, and it
will always stay that way, is called the United States dollar.
Okay. So >> Donald Trump was so based. Why didn't you Why
were you voting for him in 2016? That's freaking >> Donald
Trump says that when he's president during his first term. That
was in 2019. Donald Trump tweets it out when he's the >> Yeah.
Well, he could have voted for >> right? Well, good for
him saying that, but so Donald Trump tweets out when he's president.
Then he loses the election and he starts, you know, at some point,
I guess, you know, back when the election is like coming around,
he starts his new cryptocurrency. Someone convinced cryptocurrency,
convinc.
>> Uh, you're also missing the Trump NFT. >> Guy
who was under investigation by the justice department for crypto
stuff, invested a ton of money into Trump and Melania's crypto.
>> This is Justin Sun, right? Suddenly that investigation
disappears and Trump is all on board with crypto. >> Dude,
I as soon as Justin Sun was on Trump's team, I was like, "Oh
yeah, this guy's got to go." Okay, this guy's got to go. This
guy's the worst. >> Now, I can't read his mind. I don't
know what's going on there. To me, that seems very suspicious.
Like his motivation for changing his stance on crypto and getting
the Justice Department to drop, you know, investigation and being
in favor of weakening regula regulations of crypto seems to be
based on his own pocketbook, not based on what he thinks is actually
best for America.
if he has not if he still believes the first statement. But if
we asked him, he would obviously say, "No, I changed my mind.
You know, I was wrong when I tweeted >> Juck is a Tron
hater. Yeah, I'm a Tron hater. Who's not a Tron hater? Who knows
anything about crypto and is not a Tron hater? What >> he
he would say, "Oh, did I say that? Oh, I don't remember saying."
>> Yeah, well, that's what he was saying, so you know,
but whatever. I don't know if it's important to kind of hone
in on reading his mind because we don't know. >> yeah,
it's impossible to tell. So, I'm just going to look at the outcome
and say it looks very suspicious to me just the same way as the
whole epine handling looks very suspicious to me. Especially
now we find out supposedly people are saying senior official
supposedly leaked to the Wall Street Journal that Trump's name
is all over the Epste. >> But so on the crypto you would
put him in the lie category like he he knows he's lying. He's
he still is he still believes that crypto is a scrunch
line or he could be our caring himself and I can see either one
as being val as >> So I'm not going to >> but nowhere
near the true belief category where he actually believes it.
It's just it's in his heart to believe it. See, that's the problem.
Whenever there's a >> I'm probably going to start moving
through this pretty quickly. I don't think there's like a whole
>> of things when you're president. >> There like
some other things here, but >> all that power, all that
responsibility.
>> That was weird. People started mentioning like the doc
stuff in the >> Thank you. >> Says, "Destiny despises
the far left, but holds the same spies for the entirety of the
right. You have someone to for a moder voter and the far right
voter don't expect to win over potential voters stop loss." That
is true. That's a good point. >> Well, I guess that's kind
of why I guess he's kind of screwed himself and he's realizing,
"Oh man, I got to get in bed with the far left." >> Maybe.
Yeah, maybe.
This stream happened today. I know, but I think they stopped
talking.
>> Clearly,
I'm trying to police his jokes.
>> Conor just admitted that these people who have these
million like people audiences who Kamla did not go on and that
is a big criticism of what she should have done is are people
that want to be edgy, that want to be authentic, that don't want
to be policed and these people are now like young voters are
swinging towards Trump. So somehow how this is not a way that
we should go. We should not be more like these podcast hosts
who are like appealing to the every man the more >> where
where is Joe Rogan or Theo Vaughn ever done something like this
when when have they done this? Which one of the podcast hosts
is doing this thing? Like this is such a stupid argument. Okay,
show me one of the very popular podcast hosts who would tweet
the same thing.
>> More authentic people. We shouldn't do >> No.
Ironically, what I'm saying is this mistake, this joke, kind
of like Kyla said was more offensive than it was
>> So, it was a bad joke. And by the way, you actually
Steven made content about this where he's like, "Isn't TTO the
edgy guy? Isn't Asmin Gold the edgy guy? Don't they love [__]
on what would they debate about?" Also, Quimman made me made
up a bunch of lies about me stealing money, so that guy. That's
true. Quan Quayman says that Wick stole the the tooth fund. Okay.
And Wick got his tooth fixed. I don't know if that's >> On
Mexicans getting deported, don't they love all this [__]
>> Why? Why did Quimman lie about this guy? >> Yeah,
they do. They're hypocrites. But just because they're hypocrites
and they're stupid doesn't mean that you don't have to appeal
to them. But it does because I can look at how do they grow their
audiences? Who's the most popular political streamer in the world
right now? It's Asmin Gold. Where are all of these people think
you gained by asking or making fun of like dead kids? How many
people do you think you gained when you asked if a father of
a 12-year-old if his daughter had sex? How many people followed
you up? >> Conor's like just he hits it like so directly
and there's just no way. By the way, watch the responses. Nobody
will ever actually engage with the precise examples. They will
never say it back because they know how bad it looks, right?
That's all you need for proof because they will never engage
with the examples. They will never say, "I did uh exactly what
Connor said. I I listen I Connor I tweeted about that 12-year-old
having because it was really important for the sake of of of
moral consistency and and being consistent in my opinions." Okay.
That's what that's why I had to tweet that. Um, he'll never say
that. He'll go, "Well, edgy jokes are supposed to be fine. I
thought edgy jokes were fine." Right?
He'll never and that's the all the proof you need to know that
heed up here and he's like faking this whole thing. He will not
say what the joke was again. He'll never say it's awesome when
I do this. He'll never do it. >> People did Asmin Gold
game asking about >> What about is how many How many people
did Asmin Gold game when he made a joke about the border? How
many What about that? What about that? What about this? Never
never comes close to engagement. >> Trainer to go to catch
illegal immigrants are laughing about alligator
>> Most people hate Mexicans. Most people don't hate kids.
>> Okay, so >> Conor Connor's actually thrashing
him. And it's so funny cuz that's that's just true. It feels
to say, but yeah, tons of people hate Mexicans. Nobody hates
children. Yeah, exactly. Then the issue has nothing to do with
I guess edgy jokes, whatever. Just targeting it better, I guess.
>> I Yeah. Oh, >> that would be my argument is that
edgy jokes are totally fine. In the case of these edgy jokes,
your timing made them more offensive than they were funny. >> This
is again that question right there is just more proof that he
can't make these jokes, right? He can't. He's not socialized
well enough. He doesn't see it at all. This is just a lack of
impulse control. He was just mad. And why are we pretending that
this isn't just him continuing to be totally assigned over Donut
Operator and Brandon Herrera? Is that not like actually even
more than it just being funny or being edgy or him trying to
build audience? Is it not just him being super assigned that
those guys like sort of disavowed him, right? Like those were
the guys who were engaging in the help, right? And like trying
to do rescue and stuff and he was obviously just going after
them because he's a bitter, spiteful, low impulse control loser.
>> Wait, then your issue is edgy jokes. You can't say I
would prefer an edgy joke at a later point in time. That makes
it not an edgy joke anymore. That's the whole >> No. No.
So I think making fun of is always an edgy joke. >> Okay.
So then what then the time that you just said was completely
relevant. >> I think it's just it's so it's so weird because
again I criticize Asma Gold for this. I think the Pokemon thing
is definitely very I do think he's helping play into the the
cruelty aspect of of the of mass deportations. >> He does
make an argument about it that is based on he's he's basically
making the argument that these people are destroying the country
and therefore don't let them weaponize anything against you.
I don't agree with that argument and I think it's wrong but I
do think that's a that position which I disagree with I think
is >> yeah Adam knows Adam is just about to call it the
what aboutism right that's what's going to Adam about or off
Adam the most right is the what aboutism is this guy smiling
yeah Destiny's talked a lot of about Adam so he's enjoying watching
Destiny be like the floundering on a panel who can't make any
point to save his life and is desperately trying to disengage
with the actual criticisms so that he can make some side or some
tangent point and look like a complete to anybody above an 80
IQ. Adam's very much enjoying that. Listen, Adam is just at that
85 IQ so he can enjoy it, right?
>> Bad is a far cry difference. >> Adam is kind of
whack. I'm telling you, Adam Adam can be kind of whack. But Adam
is enjoying this because it's like very clear to anybody with
like an above room temperature IQ again that Desi is floundering
and making an of himself >> and making fun of children
dying. >> Hell yeah. >> If Asthma Gold was making
fun of immigrant children dying, I would say okay, then he can
make that comparison. But I haven't seen anything like that.
And I think even as Miguel's worst obnoxious jokes, >> bro,
you're going to cause another crash out. I warned you. Okay,
that's true, Kenny. Bro, you're going to cause another crash
out. Next time he's going to post somebody even even skinnier
and more attractive. Okay, he's just going to keep making me
hotter as his hate towards me slowly turns to like his own seething
eroticism, his own seething erotic fixation. Okay, he's just
going to keep making me hotter so he can imagine sucking my It's
very bizarre. I totally disavow. It's very gross to me. Okay.
But that is like all he's doing now. He's just going to continue
fantasizing about me being more and more attractive. I don't
know why >> did not even come that I've seen anyway has
not come close to Destiny's weird comments about the children
or the firefighter getting >> How much more are we going
to listen to? I don't know. >> I mean I have so many more
time codes. >> Oh, I don't have a heart out there. I think
so.
>> It's your call. >> That's the only way I can make
sense of him picking a picture that makes me look more attractive.
Cuz again, I'll say it one more time. Okay. I have no idea. Like
the worst part about him attempting to dox me before was posting
a picture of a super fat guy. And then I basically have the option
of like showing that I'm not fat on stream or just dealing with
it. And now he's like totally lifted that. I don't have that
at all. Right. I don't have that problem at all anymore. Thank
God. >> I also No, I literally didn't say that. Do you
want me to restate it? >> You just said it was too close
to the event essentially. That's kind of what you're going for.
It made it probably more offensive to people in the case of this
edgy joke that he made because it was so close to the event and
it was quote tweeting people actively looking for the kids. >> Oh,
they missed it. They missed that Desi does not actually respond
to what Connor says at all. Right. They just totally took the
what aboutism and and engaged with that and didn't actually engage
with like Connor and Desty pivoting away from responding. Too
bad. >> People found it more offensive than they found
it funny which why didn't hit hard. I don't personally care either
way. I do think it's ineffective in this case. I'll go ahead
and stand on business that as a 40-y old man, you shouldn't talk
about 12-year-old. That that that's my perspective,
>> Connor just hit it again. And Desty's only response
can be will be, I thought jokes I thought comedy was legal and
Trump's in office. Fascism's on the >> Agree with Connor.
>> Yeah, let me jump ahead here. >> Very sensible.
>> Very sensible. >> Oh, they don't keep going. God
damn it. >> Fight with them about voted for Trump. Unfortunately,
even if you are right to, and I think you are, I don't think
it's wrong to affiliate.
and won the election. What are you talking about? >> I'm
not done. >> Okay, we'll keep saying something wrong. >> God,
you're so impossible to talk to sometimes. Sorry, you're making
me Okay, cool. Cool. So, Trump said that Democrats or Republicans
are saying that Democrats are pests that need to be exised from
the like and they won. Like, this clearly is not like, oh, well,
it's because of a small group that it worked. No, it works when
they demonize Democrats. It works when they demonize every minority.
It works. It's interesting that they don't really talk about
the policy prescription
that they they see deportation as just demonizing and being mean.
>> All right. All right. I don't know if I'm going to do
too much more of this. I kind of want to I don't even know what
Pisco and Connor were arguing about, but I kind of want to watch
them argue. I feel like that's probably going to be a good argument.
So, we watch some of that. And what else do I have in the docket
here? I've got a couple things. I got this guy. I've got Oh,
we could cover the Vosch cancellation. Oh, actually, little pallet
cleanser. Our president is far more implicated in the >> Coffeezilla
update on the Epstein files and Trump far more implicated than
we thought before. >> Files than we previously thought.
This is according to >> I might I might end up doing more
of this. I'm just going to wait and probably I don't know listen
to it passively in the background and and do more timestamps
on it and stuff just so I'm not listening the whole time. >> Wall
Street Journal article. The Justice Department told Trump in
May that his name is among many in the Epstein files. A lot of
people are going to tell you, "Oh, that's old news. We knew he
was in the flight logs. We knew he was in these phone records,
but that's not what we're talking about. Those were already public.
Jeffrey's black book that was already out there. This is a new
review of documents that we're talking about. We're going to
go through all of it. And we're going to start with Trump actually
being asked directly if he was told by his attorney general whether
he was mentioned in the Epstein files. And he says, "No." No.
>> Did she tell you at all that your name appeared in the
in the >> No, no. She's uh she's given us
just a very quick briefing. So there we have Trump denying being
told that his name was in the Epstein files. But a lot of people
were wondering, well then why are you acting so weird with these
files? >> Are you still talking about Jeffrey
>> It's pretty boring stuff. They were made up by Obama.
>> Luckily, we unearthed an interview where Trump actually
hints to the fact that he was in fact told that he was in the
Epstein files and it was all fake stuff. >> They've been
running these files and so >> I think I dropped a couple
mini. Destiny is a freak intimidating victims currently chats
in such an Adam stream. LOL's
I if they engage with them it'd be pretty funny because we found
with me now that file